ça allez hop sa part ça doit marcher ça
doit fonctionner on devrait avoir la
partie de maxime sous nos yeux
très rapidement il va falloir essayer de
choper des caméras surtout ça va être ça
la complexité donc la game je laisse
donc ça j'ai envie de dire c'est
perfecto on est d'accord on voit bien
l'échiquier on voit tout on est d'accord
le clic ados marche leçon marche tout
marche si on n'a pas les calmes
honnêtement alors attendez on a des
calmes on a des calmes un peu bizarre
mais on va te chercher la cam de maxime
c'est maxime s'en est bien d'accord
vous savez quoi il ya un truc qui m'a
saoulé dans leur design
regardez ce que je vais faire je vais
faire un truc ils vont pas être contents
mais c'est pas grave vous allez voir ce
que je vais faire
en fait moi je vais me virer là je vais
me mettre en petit comme ça et là calmes
en vrai je vais la mettre en grand au
dessus parce que ballack en fait
en fait on va vraiment faire comme nous
on a envie ça va être le concept en fait
certains en fait je vais le mettre là
ont bien grand est d'accord je l'enlever
mon nom c'est pas grave on va mettre lvl
car jaeckin et moi en fait je vais me
mettre comme ça vous allez voir l mon
idée en fait c'est de faire le cast un
peu comme ça en vrai c'est pas genre
mieux que ce qu'ils ont fait genre au
lieu de mettre le commentateur en méga
grand est là car mon petit en fait nous
on va faire à la nous on va mettre on va
avec le marlou en grand et on est
parfait et en fait l'échiquier alors
attendez l'échiquier n'est pas bien
cadré mais c'est pas grave on va cadre
inquiétez pas vous inquiétez pas vous
inquiétez pas on va 4 dans l'important
c'était d'avoir maxime en fait et on va
faire un type de live en fait on regarde
maximin j'ai envie de dire le live ça va
être regardé maximin donc comme prévu
hier un est annoncée china le lab de la
berlinoise 1 ça a été annoncé un par le
streamer français bah ouais c'est normal
de mettre la cam en grands noms mais
regardez on va pouvoir regarder maxime
toute la journée
tiens je m en dessous de maxime en fait
balech des règles regarde je suis là
aussi regarder deux marlou c'est pas
beau ça
2 marlou l'un à côté de l'autre est ce
qu'on est
bien franchement je me mettrais bien je
vais mettre là en fait je me mets la
bleue mais là je veux mon petit ballack
je me rappelle this faut vraiment que
qu'on a envie de voir le marlou en grand
donc là c'est hyper théorique 1 c'est la
petite finale de la berlinoise
on a notre max inquiet bien ils jouent
tous tempo il s'est préparé le marlou
deuxième gamme avec baky ou holiday de
marloux on peut faire un double calmes
avec baky c'est pas con ça serait que de
chaises comme ils n'y ont pas pensé à
faire de faire un double calmes avec
baky on va essayer de voir si à baky en
cam on va on va laisser le truc se
passer on va voir si on a un bac et
ambulants cam 1 min et chic et miniers
chiquet c'est pas grave moi je veux je
pense uncam de ba qui quoique est ce
qu'on a vraiment besoin des deux car en
même temps je suis pas sûr on peut faire
un échiquier baky en dessous en vrai il
ya mon nom et mon prénom ouais on va
changer parce qu'en fait du come on a
tout changé on va changer nv lubaki
suivons qui s'est franchement c'est pas
beau ça décrire mv lubaki on s'est pas
placé mevel mais ça pourrait être bas
qui on ne sait pas en vrai je pense
qu'on va mettre nouvelle car jaeckin et
on va faire la même scène on double un
peu trop haut c'est ultra théorique tu
as les gars en vrai je n'arrive même pas
écrire son nom c'est terrible car
iachini orge et mie2i c'est pas possible
mais c'est pas possible j'arrive
vraiment pas en fait ce qui se passe
ok c'est le truc qui bug c'est pas
possible c'est le truc qui me guerre en
fait c'est il ya eu un truc qui allaient
vers la gauche alors hier j'ai tour
d'éviter il se lève il fait le malin car
yakine allez va falloir que le ministre
le punisse elle a pu la punissent ada
qui peut partir à tout moment
enfin le marlou réfléchi il réfléchit ça
y est réfléchie qu'est ce qu'il fait là
question garde ils cherchent pas qu'ils
chargent bas qui chargent macky sall et
ça réfléchit les avis ça y est c'est la
réflexion qui part côté ministère non
mais il cherchait quelque chose ils
cherchaient des yeux pâquis pourquoi il
après son fauteuil c'est vrai qu'ils ont
tous des petites chaises là qui sont
imparfaits d'heure c'est cool parce que
c'est l'échiquier numéro sept et on nous
l'a mis alors que normalement je pense
qu'on devrait pas la voir est ce que
c'est quoi les autres cas mon vrai
attendait mince du coup on attendait on
va on va en manger juste un oeil aux
autres cam vite fait histoire de savoir
c'est qui ça
c'est pas fait de ses gaffes avec les
blancs
c'est juste pour voir un peu nos options
en fait regarde un peu ce qu'ils ont
foutu on regarde un peu nos options
qu'est ce qu'on à qui on a au cam en
fait
ok après ça va fait refouler compétition
féminine
je pense donc qu'il ya quatre gammes ya
quoi regardez ils ont oublié de procéder
génie ils ont oublié le ils font des
réglages
ils font des réglages brightness fancast
attendait donc en fait on a une cam
carlson et s'y tiennent co
ok une qui s'amusent à rigoler un petit
peu bon là ils sont en train de régler l
arcam mais c'est car le sel ça c'est ce
vide l'air
donc on a ce vide l'air car le sel
marlou ou fait d'autres seief bon on a
pas baki au moins ça règle le problème
on va rester sur maxime
bon on est bien voilà on va passer notre
journée regardez maxime on est on va
passer une belle journée le président
censurer la presse et les partis
féminine tant qu y parvenons mais c'est
ça nous en fait on va rester sur mvele
on est bien il est beau façon j'ai envie
de dire on pourrait passer la journée
sur mv non
je peux mettre uniquement les ch'tis de
baky web on ira voir un petit peu plus
tard c'était histoire de se faire un
avis sur ce qu'on avait pour passer une
bonne journée ensemble
pourquoi ne pas juste rendre fou ici ça
est ce que quelqu'un veut que j'explique
l'idée de la berlinoise la finale de la
berlinoise où tout le monde le sait déjà
pourri ce que vous comprenez tout cette
finale est ce qu'on a à faire à des
génies dans le chat ou pas alors est ce
que cette position vous comprenez les
deux pelés les tenants et les
aboutissants ouais c'est bon tu dis on
connaît frère là bas on connaît tous un
je pense qu'on est sur un public de
connaisseurs un plan pour pour les
quelques-uns qui connaîtraient pas en
gros c'est simple apposition des noirs
paris pour y visuellement
d'ailleurs quand on a commencé à jouer
cette variante au début on pensait que
c'était pas terrible pour les noirs et
c'était plus une ouverture qu'on jouait
pour rentrer dans une finale alors
pourquoi c'est pas très bon visuellement
déjà on a des pions doublait dans une
majorité c'est à dire que là on encadre
v3 et que quand on encadre v3 avec des
pions doublé c'est impossible de créer
un pion passer si on n'a que les fins
les pions seul ne pourrons pas créer
deux pions passé alors que de l'autre
côté les blancs en quatre contre trois
avec une majorité visuellement propre
puisqu'il ya pas de pions doublé on peut
imaginer faire f4 f5 6 les noirs au delà
de ça au lieu de ce pot delà de ce
premier problème
ils ont un problème de développement
c'est que ils ont le roi qui est des
rockets sur une colonne ouverte passer
encore dégueulasse ils ont un temps de
retard de développement puisque les
blancs ont déjà eu développer une toux
en quelque sorte fait en tout cas ils
ont déjà rockies ont développé le roi ce
qui n'est pas le cas des noirs et en
plus haut c'est aux blancs de jouer donc
structure de pions dégueulasse retard de
développement dynamisme des le
dégueulasse donc en gros visuellement
les noirs on te demande qu'est ce que tu
fais pour quoi tu joues en fait en vrai
il n'y a aucune raison que les noirs ne
soit pas très mal mais le problème des
le problème des blancs c'est qu'ils leur
restent que le foot cases noires et le
pion et e5 le pion seront eux quattron
contrôlerait des cases blanches et ce
serait assez facile de
de jouer davantage mais avec le pion aux
sinko le truc c'est que ça va partie
s'arrête un problème d'envoyer le f4 au
f sinko parce que les noirs vont faire
des blocus sur case blanche
alors ils vont céder avec h5 etc vous
allez le voir il va faire h3 donc fait
ça c'est un peu préparatifs 3,8 cavale
et ses 3 h 5
donc ils empêchent tout léger quatre
fois f4 fawcett tour d un faux aux 6 kg
cinq tours à six heures ça c'est un coup
aussi très thématique de cette ouverture
le tour h6 c'est pour sûr cavaliers pros
aussi ce pouvoir reprendre de la tour
tour eu un tour des huit tours prend des
8,3 prend des huit donc le truc c'est si
les blancs réussissent à faire j'ai
quatre f4 f5 c'est terminé mais si les
noirs empêchent ils vont réussir à
tranquillement égaliser et faire nul
voire même parfois prendre l'aventage
est-ce que j'ai bien expliqué ou pas
j'essayais d'expliquer le mieux possible
l'objectif était d'essayer de faire
quelque chose pour résumer un peu les
tenants et les aboutissants quel rapport
avec berlin j'en sais rien pas donc gg
panique les noirs avaient la perte de
fou mais en fait c'est plus le truc du
blocus sur case blanche
donc là il
c'est encore théorique ou pas oui je
vois dans le peut dans la grosse base
c'est sûr qu'ils auraient plus de parti
a raconté l'histoire de l'ouverture en
lien avec rami quand j'ai déjà fait 100
fois mais en gros c'est kramis qui a
décidé de jouer cette ouverture dans son
match contre kasparov
parce qu'ils pensaient kasparov seraient
pas très bons en finale mais il a eu un
peu de bol parce qu'ils pensaient que
les blancs étaient quand même mieux mais
que ça qu'on s'était bien pour jouer
contre garer mais le truc c'est que
fondamentalement c'est une bonne
ouverture en plus de ça on a joué départ
et disparaître une seconde il faut que
alors on nous dit la chose suivante
à tours alors c'est vrai mais ça perd
beaucoup de choses aurais tu gagnes la
tour mais tu perds beaucoup en échange
donc ça ce serait une très mauvaise idée
pour les blancs et en fait ça à perdre
immédiatement nord une pièce de moins
d'habitude les joueurs jours vous
prendrez 8
après il ya peu deux parties un façon ça
a été ré analysé c'est sûr que ces
prépas le problème de se faire
surprendre en premier ici pour maxime
sait que si on reprend des 8es
fondamentalement bon et que maxime
trouve pas vraiment comment mettre la
pression
ça peut être nul très facile pour les
noirs et donc sur cavale et prend ici
s'il veut tout reprendre six ans avec
les noirs très clairement c'est le seul
coût possible
saâd hariri bien le bonjour bonjour à
toi saviem par correspondance a conduit
par g4 ok je comprends j'ai quatre
longues rangées 4 ça peut donner quoi ça
voici le comprendre on va essayer de
comprendre sans utiliser de turbines
alors souvent quand on fait ce gk puis
on prend pions prend on a une envie de
faire cavalier h4 ici sont une bonne
case pour le cavalier pour deux raisons
je lirai ont déjà en fait on n'a
peut-être pas trop le choix ont
peut-être allant des quatre mais vrai
copain qui a décapité possible en fait
on peut rebondir angers 6 dans certains
monde où on tape des choses et on menace
aussi fou prendrait 5 fu pranger cinq
cavaliers f3 fourchette ou triplette
donc g4 si on prend lyon prend cavaler
h4 ce serait logique je dirais tour 3 du
coup visuellement pour couvrir est ici
va savoir ce qu'il faut faire ici va ça
ce qu'il faut faire avec les noms à
risque ya un flou pranger car non au
projet quartier prend f7 peut-être 3,8
en fait le roi il est peu de paille peut
être bien passé l'autre côté mais là
c'est pas mal ce qui peut bloquer la
structure du coup menace ou pranger 4
sur f3 il doit y avoir des cavaliers g6
arias même fou ces cinq cavaliers g6 qui
peuvent être relooké g6 à quel point ici
c'est donc à parme est fou c'est 5
ça c'est mort
du coup peut-être on prendrait aussi se
prendre 6 fou g3 chasse le cheval en
fait il fait cai g6 l'idée c'était de
faire f 4 et 6 fait g5
enfin il est protégé mais si ferrer 5
fait reprise prises et f4 et là on va
enfin l'aïe a poussé 5 encore mais jure
que si on réussit à faire ça on va être
mieux et ça on va y arriver en fait
d'une manière x ou y fait si on a une
structure comme ça on va y arriver mais
le problème c'est vrai qu'on menace pas
f4 direct mm
fêtons g6 en fait on n'a pas de f3 ya
poussé 5 et tours 4 bon on presse quand
même avec les plans on a la belle
structure
si on réussit à faire un rouage de roi
jean iii f4 on est gagnant presque
on va retourner la danse que ça assez
critique g4 bouffe bouffe cavaler h
quatre tours 3 logique 3,8 donc tour 3
pour éviter les quatre élèves 3.8
logique se fout on va quand même pas
laisser prendre angers 4 tours g3 assez
bizarre donc on va prendre
il reprend cette position elle par
ailleurs elle paraît quasi forcée en
fait valait pas tout à fait forcer
measure que les blancs peuvent quasiment
la force et parce que cavalia h4 semble
quand même être le coup le plus logique
et là on pense on pas loin avec les
blancs d'être mieux mais c'est toujours
ça avec cette berlinoise toujours
l'impression d'être à deux doigts d'être
mieux en fait
mais le truc c'est que s'il réussit à
nous planter un g5 qui a réalisé ici ça
nous bloquer on sera pas mieux est-ce
que tours troyes c'est sûr c'est pas sûr
jacques cavallier des cats est aussi
possible quand même mes cahiers des cats
a peut-être un truc avec cavaliers pros
au 6e tour des uns et des cats il doit y
avoir un problème sur la colonne donc
avalé h4 c'est le coup logique de toute
façon sa part est ce que tours troyes et
forcé
ça la gueule d'un truc fort c'est quand
même
ils menacent quoi ils menacent pas
encore floues pranger ça il faut prendre
les 5 c sur échec mais menace tour g6
amenant à cavaler proxy socis en a
peut-être un temps paul à
la tête un coup de tampon parce qu'il
menace pas encore floues pranger 5
il faut prendre les tours et tour g6 qui
avait promis si c'est sur échec donc on
a un coût pour temporiser mais est-ce
qu'on a quelque chose à faire
tourné autour des 3 rue mais en fait
c'est pas logique de donner un échec
tu donnes un coût gratuit en fait ce
tour troyes et tours d un tour des trois
c'est la même chose sauf que sur tours
troyes les noirs veulent 3,8 donc si tu
fais tour d un roi 8 tours 3
c'est l'équivalent que si tu avais fait
tour trois rois à 8 mais là on veut
surtout retrouver à huit a pas envie de
jouer autour des 3 le roi il est de
toute façon mal placé donc ça sert à
rien de mettre un échec mais c'est vrai
qu'ici on a un coût libre alors est ce
que on à f3 roy au 8 rue f 2 ça ça peut
être précis preset parce que du coup on
va vouloir mettre le range étroit et ça
ça peut être pression ça ça peut être
pression donc f3 ça peut être une option
pour wave ii maintenant il faut voir ce
qui a plein de coups ici y'a pas que roy
jay a poussé 5 en fait juste
padalka suroît f1 il ya poussé quatre
rois sur la colonne h découverte donc
foudroie fou prend tout reprend et roy e
set carélie g6
complexe complexe qu'on a peut-être le
temps de roulage et de roy g3 et le truc
c'est que je répète ainsi on arrive à
faire f 4 f 5 on va être mieux
complexe
c'est pas absolument évident que que les
blancs soient mieux mais c'est de toute
façon c'est les blancs qui essayent à
aucun moment là pour le moment
enfin dans cette partie jusqu'à
maintenant où on est inquiet pour maxime
après le truc c'est que à ce niveau là
en fait là c'est cariat keynes est le
premier joueur que l'on rencontre qui
est vraiment du top niveau mondial et
donc
à voir les noirs dans la deuxième on
peut subir une prépa une poussette
geci rappelle chance de faire annuler
cette position je pensais 80% de chance
deux nuls 17 % victoire maxime 3% des
fêtes comme ça je vais avoir un truc
avec une variété de try hard way il a
arrêté de travailler ram mais il a des
beaux restes 1 il était top mondial a
enfin il a été numéro deux mondial avec
aria keane il a failli battre mag nice
dans un match pour le titre de champion
du monde donc c'est un peu comme baky en
fait en quelque sorte car yakine sur ce
tournoi il sait motiver il envoie du
lourd
il n'ya pas les caméras sur baky celle
event
c'est un des gros even d'échec au monde
mais malheureusement il ya que quatre
caméras sur le tournoi complexe c'est un
petit peu dommage de pas ne pas en avoir
huit quand même c'est pas c'est pas ces
po1 quatre caméras
surtout que vu vu les cams et des carmes
fixings c'est un trépied uncam là ya pas
de bail à un gars qui se déplacent même
est sûr c'est qu'à menacer des canes
fixe
moi je veux avoir une vie caméra pour
avoir 8,8 en anglais sur huit angles sur
baky vrai je suis penché sur la chaîne
ce cas les caméras exactement est ce que
vous trouvez que ça offre une grosse
plus-value d'air la position l'analyse
et je l'expliqué après ça s'appelle
maxime de trouver nous on n'a rien
trouvé pour les blancs
et qui réussissent
prem de cavalli aussi c'est qu'on va
faire tout reprendre
j'ai pas ça valait 6 minutes de pub on
en discutera en fera un bilan à la fin
de la compétition
si vous trouvez que ça vaut vraiment pas
les 6000 de pub on ne fera plus en fait
et puis basta rhin donka
va voir là il n'y a plus grand chose à
dire honnêtement on peut aller voir la
position de ba qui j'ai envie on a fait
le tour on a vraiment fait le tour ici
et bah qui allait déjà visuellement ça
me plaît c'est une espagnole ça ok c'est
ça n'a rien de fou c'est 5
ces théories tout ça on ça suit des
partis on va pas trop se plonger parce
qu'on va pas tout suivre en même temps
mais en gros ça a l'air d'être prêt pas
ça à l'air d'être prépa
je vous presque tout
cela donc je préfère toujours les blancs
en fait pour expliquer les blancs un
énorme avantage à long terme ces espions
des six qui est faible mais le problème
c'est qu'il ya de l'activité les noirs
ils sont mieux développer un ça se voit
assez visuel on voit bien que les pièces
elles sont sorties même si elles sont
pas sur des cases idéal c'est surtout
les deux fous qui tape en fait les
cavaliers sont pas très bien placé
la question c'est est ce qu'avec les
blancs on va réussir à digérer notre
avantage du pion et finir notre
développement quelqu'un on aura un bel
avantage parce que ce pion des scissions
réussi à stabiliser à mon avis va être
perdue tôt ou tard ou est-ce qu'on n'a
pas le temps ça la question
et surtout reprendre ici se passe quoi
alors j'imagine je veux y mettre la
turbine est je pensais que c'était déjà
gagnant alors là c'est vraiment
ordinateur est ce qu mois de badges
penser que c'est un truc comme ça mais
je vais sûrement me faire réfuté parce
que c'est parce qu'ils proposent et
qu'on allait s'activer de ouf
mais le truc c'est que là dessus à fouet
trois apparemment et le cavalier va
pouvoir venir en d2 et on menace aussi
b4 avec le clouage donc ça c'est pénible
donc la première intuition fonctionnait
pas mais du coup le coup c'est fou f5
mais ça c'est sûr qu'il connaît si l'on
analyse à la maison est un peu bizarre
parce que on vient de douche réfugiés 4
on file un pion en un pour reculer le
fou mais le truc on va essayer de
comprendre ensemble c'est sûrement qu'il
veut taper avec du cac valeo 4 fou prend
f2 sur foot pro f 5 cavaliers pro f 5
on va vite arriver et j'en suis un coup
comme tour des cinq as du tour dès 8h
vérifier c'est ça à tourcoing f5 à tour
matt et le fait d'avoir supprimé le fou
ça donne accès à des 1
qu'on ait une info donc chaud et donc
tokheim ici car akin carlsen mvl fraysse
aussi sur cette ligne super solide ouais
ça une tête de solides de ses la partie
à une nouvelle fresque du top du top 12
maxime avait obtenu un pion de plus mais
en vrai avant ça ça aurait pu ça aurait
pu être compliqué où c'est où c'est une
autre game la game qui avaient vite fait
en fait mais donc du coup tu reprends
des six fonctionne pas mons était sûr
après ces prépas et on dit fou et 3 ici
vous prend pions prend et d5 sûrement
choses comme ça on à la paire de fou il
ya le pion faible mais probablement le
fait que les pions soient doublés pose
problème ça va donner des cases aux
chevaux je préférerais la jouer avec les
blancs ça s'est il n'y avait même pas de
débat mais ça doit ça doit être bien
solide pour les noirs calme ça doit être
bien solide donc je disparais pour me
mouche à chaque fois
a obligé un pas le choix mouche aide
et qui les deux cas où vous falloir
cavale et des deux c'est un coup aussi
très intéressant parce que ça protège
ça protège le cheval après peut-être
qu'il veut du dessin qu'avait lieu
quatre choses comme ça on a du mal à
bouger
peut-être h 3o h5 g4 ou g6 bouffe
puisque ça ce serait possible j'y crois
pas en fait ça ça donc là trop de cases
qui s'affaiblissent c'est c'est très
active après c'est là ce genre de truc
ce genre de variante très concrète c'est
très analyse et surtout c'est dur de
donner un avis stratégiques là dessus
parce que si on allume la turbine
absolument tout va se faire et futée
pour les blancs c'est quasiment sûr que
les noirs peuvent aller chercher
l'égalité en force
d'après en partie tu peux avoir des
idées pratiques qui pose des problèmes
au noir mais clairement ça doit ça doit
tenir pour pour pour pure hoon sur un
jeu parfait bien évidemment un peu
retourné sur max pour faire un petit
tour juste et si piennes co karlsson qui
est une belle affiche un bond à
l'affiché scipione qu il faut qu'ils
gagnent pour avoir une place au grand
prix fidh c'est terrible pour lui que
magnus en huitièmes c'est le pire moment
pour pour être appareils contre magnus
mais après j'ai vu sur son interview en
russie hier dans une interview une
interview pour le chase comme maurice
j'ai regardé du coup il était très très
très heureux de jouer contre manu 108e
et il avait envie de perf est d'aller le
chercher
je rappelle qu'il avait battu avec un
sûre qu'il soit moins fort hein
après bien sûr en terme d'équité
sportive c'est vraiment pas de bol pour
lui donc ça ça peut être un match
intéressant et vident leurs chants clan
qui serait le le prochain adversaire du
vainqueur du match de maxime là ces deux
joueurs qui doivent parfaitement
convenir à maxime au prochain tour donc
j'ai envie de dire peut-être willer
fondamentalement plus fort mais d'un
autre côté c'est vraiment un client pour
maximy le bas à chaque fois j'irai quand
même c'est mieux de jouer de vie leurs
un gars que tu va réellement
systématiquement même si intrinsèquement
il est probablement un peu plus fort que
shankland ya il ya quand même l'avantagé
psychologique qui joue
donc on retourne sur la position de
maxou le truc c'est que c'est un client
et quand il quand tu joues contre un
joueur que tu as vraiment beaucoup battu
c'est un avantage
question à partir de quand il improvise
se laissent parler leur imagination et
le talent alors voilà par exemple
fischer caps et c'est une bonne question
posée à ce moment là puisque là on tombe
sur une position que maxime ne connaît
pas ou il ne se rappelle pas donc il ya
beaucoup étudié la position avec
l'ordinateur donc savez qu'il ya
beaucoup de plans qui vont être tirées
de ce qu'il a vu avec l'ordinateur
cependant là en 16e coup de la partie et
c'est le premier coup ou y réfléchit
jusqu'à maintenant ils avaient toujours
et tempo et là on est déjà sûr bonne 25
minutes dehors peut-être même un peu
plus on est sur 28 29 minutes de
réflexion déjà évident n'a pas collé à
maxime julien faut se pencher sur paris
ouais mais bon ça c'est un tournoi qui
ne compte pour rien maxime avait joué la
française
on voit bien que c'est pas du tout ce
que je vous ai toujours expliqué c'est
que ces tournois là comme le grand duché
ce tour comme les tournois sur internet
etc
c'est pas le c'est pas le même enjeu
donc les joueurs jouent tranquillement
c'est pas la même chose
franchise ne se regardent pas non à l'or
fin et changé deux pièces contre contre
une tour est un pion neuf fois sur dix
est mauvais c'est que cas spéciaux où ça
peut aller mais là ça se voit
visuellement que c'est un cas spécial
il ya une pas une qualité puisqu'il perd
une pièce puis une deuxième qui gagne
pas une qualité et hyper deux pièces
pour la tour ces visuels que ces visuels
que les les blancs sont mal le pouvoir
revenir en russie c'est les deux fous
des coupes l'échiquier les deux fous
sont beaucoup plus fort qu'une tour
s'annonce sur cavaliers pros ou six pour
essayer de prendre le fou l'idée c'est
tout reprend de toute façon je vais vous
dire un truc sic arias qui n'a toujours
été un pot pour là c'est le cas donc
comme cariat qui n'a toujours et mpo
avec les noirs et qui semble connaître
c'est impossible que maxime sur le jeu
parfait de karuïa qu'il puisse gagner
en fait je parfait de karuïa keane donne
forcément nul
maintenant ce que maxime essaye de
trouver c'est une position où il va être
difficile pour car yakine de faire jeu
parfait mais là si on voit maxime un
petit peu comment dire avant petite
lassitude dans le calcul est et on sent
qu'il est il n'est pas très content le
langage corporel donne cette impression
c'est parce que maxime il est il le sait
est ce que je suis en train de vous dire
il le sait ce coup là soit ils se
rappellent plus où hélas pas long de
fichiers et il sait que fondamentalement
il n'y a pas davantage
donc là il va aller essayer de chercher
quelque chose qui soit 1 pose un
problème pratique à l'adversaire soit 2
comme il veut pas se retrouver moins
bien qu'ils aillent faire nul en force
mais n'attend pas
le choix il s'est fait prépare c'est
très difficile et tu sais que tout ce
que tu calcules de toute façon il y aura
jamais davantage mais j'ai pour la
cameroun pour la can n'empêche j'ai bien
fait d'écrire hier matin sans rigoler
parce qu'on n'a pas maquiller ya que 4
cam dont une sur sur sur les deux russes
en fait j'avais trois cam qui était
forcément prise j'ai envie de dire mais
bon ça car iachini long il l'aurait mis
dans tous les cas je pense donc on était
tranquille mais clairement ça a été bien
d'assurer la cam
l'acca même veulent parce qu on aurait
pu ne pas l'avoir 1,4 calmes sur sur
huit partis c'est pas énorme
ensuite maxou peut aller chercher la
wind final avoir bien sûr il fait partie
dans sa partie de tableau en fait les
deux femmes c'est la demi finale avant
l'heure entre guillemets
ba qui s'en sort comme en bas quand on a
regardé c'était près pas de l'adversaire
là il paraît qu'il a joué un coup fait
voir ça il a joué tout reprendre et 6
ouais donc normalement ça va continuer
prépa fouet f5 etc
j'espère qu'il connaît bien bas qui y
ait quoi que je vérifie que ça va
bientôt reprendre ici c'est parce que ça
bug un peu poète on reprend des six fois
f5 tempo de pure rhône
ok ça ça peut être mauvaise nouvelle ça
être mauvaise nouvelle parce que pure
rooney doit bien connaître et il va
aller il va aller égaliser genre de
manière directe on est plutôt mauvais
début de partie des français avec les
blancs disons que on n'est pas moins
bien mais on n'a pas de poussettes pour
le moment ce qu'on cherche ici c'est
juste d'avoir poussé atteint j'ai envie
de dire pousse à être suffit ici c'est
ce qu'on cherche on cherche on cherche
ni plus ni moins que pouces et à la
poussette à baky tempo aussi ok donc
peut-être il se rappelle du fuite du
fichier on va voir
pourquoi les camions sur les russes
parce que le tournoi organisé en russie
en tout bonnement elle et pls et après
plus forte audience non on est peut-être
audience numéro 1 en organique on est
numéro un au monde donc j'ai envie de te
dire on est tranquille on est bien à
d'ailleurs on est même c'est ouf on est
même devant devant deux chaises comme
international terrible pour la chaîne
d'un certain daniel air bien connu dans
le milieu du streaming
je vais recevoir de nouveau des messages
ça va être terrible ans ça va repartir
en message il va y avoir assez de pub
cette fois ci ah bah on se présente un
petit peu quand même hein on se présente
c'est pas exactement la définition du
jeu de tempo jouer à tempo ça veut dire
jouer instantanément
ça va demander des conseils en vraie
licence puis on m'a dit qu'il
s'inspirait des stream et qui regardait
ce que je faisais parce qu'il trouvait
que c'était assez incroyable et je crois
qu'ils se sont inspirés de moi notamment
en tout cas de mes conseils depuis
longtemps pour enlever la barre
d'évaluation et je crois qu'ils car on
en a parlé sur son live ya deux jours
que lui aussi rejoignez finalement le
côté obscur de la force et du fait que
mettre les bars d'évaluation n'était pas
forcément une bonne idée
en tout cas hikaru lille a rejoint le
côté obscur de la force
et de chasse comme pas encore mais il ya
des discussions là-dessus
et s'il faut garder la barre ou pas là
ils l'ont décès je crois qu'ils veulent
plus la m c'est plus aussi systématique
qu'avant en vrai de vrai avant c'était
systématique surtout les lives et
maintenant ça ne l'est plus c'est ça la
décision du stream heures après ils ont
tous misé par inertie mais laissait plus
c'est plus quelque chose de graver dans
le marbre comme avant on va dire ça
comme ça
et d'après ce que j'ai entendu sur le
live 10 karuk j'ai regardé en replay
après qu'un qu'un seul mais me raconter
ça c'est que oui car ou est il qu'à
rouen fait il est plus ou moins du même
avis que moi en fait en vrai on est
d'accord sur plein de trucs avec hikaru
sutton a un petit peu de temps en temps
mais en vrai je crois qu'on a vraiment
une vision des choses assez proche lui
et moi or troll bon après on est
complètement oubliée de troll tout le
temps parce que bon cet homme n'est
qu'un streamer il faut le rappeler mais
en vrai de vrai je le crois qu'on est
d'accord sur sur l'essentiel on reproche
quoi dedans
révélée par d'évaluation ça on parle
plus des chèques on regarde une barre et
du coup c'est au bout d'un moment c'est
relou quoi il faut il faut il faut
éduquer les gens à aimer les échecs
parce que c'est un art en fait les
échecs c'est un art donc il faut il faut
avoir cette éducation d'un peut sentir
la partie est plus être sûr il a joué le
meilleur coup leur dis pas leurs
couleurs d sinon c'est pas marrant c'est
d'être un peu sur voilà les échecs il se
passe des choses c'est un combat entre
deux hommes
et on n'est pas la regarder à chaque
fois benchmark les coûts avec
l'ordinateur quoi j'aurais joué qui les
prend ici alors sur sûr qu'ils avaient
des problèmes 6 les noirs font et feront
du sisu prend 1,6 il faut dire à tous
adversaires qu'il est complètement nul
ça s'est un peu problématique donc avec
proxy s'il veut ton points 6 c'est un
duel d'humains et donc et donc c'est
comme ça pas très smooth way
donc à voir comment comment ça évolue
apprend même temps pour des pilotes
comme nous on voit pas celui ci rend
tout ce que tu vois m et moi non plus je
vois pas tous en fait ça qu'il faut voir
c'est que moi non plus en fait je sais
pas tu vois là je sais que l'évaluation
c'est égal je voulais dit mais en vrai
je suis pas assis à leur place je suis
en train de commenter jeudi le chat je
sais pas pour qui peut-être que je me
plante en fait peut-être que d'un point
de vue pratique c'est plus facile à
jouer avec les noirs mais la barre
d'évaluation ne va pas donner la réponse
soit si on la met la barre des vals elle
va donner quoi afje avoir d'évaluation
si on va la mettre
elle donne petit avantage blanc +0 31
pour déjà je suis absolument pas
d'accord c'est forcément prépa à fond de
karuïa keane est donc en vrai c'est
fifty-fifty et après d'un point de vue
pratique pour lequel des deux joueurs
c'est mieux on n'en sait rien donc du
coup en fait cette barre d'évaluation
cccc les vals du pauvre quoi ça veut
rien dire en fait en vrai on sait pas
donc vu qu'on sait pas au lieu de tout
le monde et les yeux rivés là-dessus bas
autant discuter de la pause et là on
avait dit quoi comme coup on avait dit
j'ai quattro et ses jouets
ag cavaliers h4 pour avoir joué un peu
ces trucs avec les blancs c'est hyper
dangereux pour les blancs c'est vrai il
sous la halle or bizarrement je dirais
que tu vois les parties se retourner
jusqu'à dans les dents à un cavalier des
cas tu vois
nous on avait cavaliers h4 comme prépa
et on va qui a rayé des cadres dans la
gueule tempo prépare aide parce que
cavaler des cats et pas le coup numéro 1
clairement t'as pas envie de te [ __ ]
en face du roi il connaît un quart
jaeckin et il se lève tempo ils savent
direct il retourne faire le concours de
marche un adversaire de gros calibre là
pour le concours de marche marche côté
maxime il va falloir se battre un ça va
mettre tellement la pression de te faire
tempo achats kubala en fait ce qui se
passe psychologiquement
qu'est-ce qui c'est quoi le discours
l'antre les joueurs c'est maxime il
vient de calculer pendant 40 minutes et
carla qui il est en train de dire à
maxime frérot
moi j'ai même pas commencé à jouer en
fait là tu joues encore contre ma
turbine à la maison en gros c'est ça
qu'il est en train lui dire après il ya
quelque chose de très important à savoir
et sa maxime le sait et cardiaques le
sait aussi
mais ils arriveront sortie de prépa
genre le 1er ou 2e le premier coup tu
joues or prépa il arrive assez souvent
que ce soit une grosse connerie ça c'est
un truc qui arrive parce que t'es pas
encore rentré dans la partie
tu joues un premier coup vraiment
important loin de là partent loin
vraiment loin et j'ai passé un peu comme
si imaginer au tennis on va reprendre
l'exemple du tennis tu as un gars qui a
joué tout un set
et toi tu arrives sans échauffement et
tu joues le tie break c'est chaud même
si t'as pas la fatigue physique rentrer
dans le match c'est toujours difficile
vous voyez aussi au rugby des fois tu as
un joueur qui rentre il a besoin de 3 4
minutes pour rentrer dedans ou au foot
on fait jamais rentrer un joueur sur
corner en défense normalement parce
qu'il va pas être bien sûr le marquage
et c est donc il peut arriver que le
truc le fait d'être bien préparés alors
s'arrête ça reste rare mais ça arrive
que le fait d'être bien préparé ça se
retourne contre le joueur bien préparés
parce qu'il réussit pas rentrés dans la
partie en fait au bond
non est ce que c'est possible de cavale
et deux des quatre soit du bluff 100%
non parce que c'est un coût qui pourrait
théoriquement perdre en ligne après un
tour d un je sais pas tu ne connais rien
mais jean retour des 1 c5 bouffe bouffe
et cava lieu de ça pourrait gagner en
ligne parce que sa menace c3 donc ça
rend gros visuellement ça gagne injuste
je sais pas pourquoi
que dit la petite turbine la turbine du
g5 issifou j'ai trois tours à 6 égale la
prépa d'enfoirés à 4 tours 6 ces trois
tours b 6b 4/10 entoure ces six tours
des trois-tours c4 f3c 5 avantages noire
remet ok mais comment donc quel monde
dans quel monde si c'est toi qui joues
genre moi je vois ça en partie je me dis
puisse plus - en fait je gagne un pion
mais en fait il va te harceler avec la
tour il va finir par te canin pions
parce qu'il a dû g-sync haut et qui a le
pion g4 qui se retrouve mal oui et
d'ailleurs de faire rentrer les deux
joueurs la finale de l'euro italie
angleterre c'est typiquement cet exemple
l'entraîneur fait rentrer deux joueurs
pour justifier les penaltys il semble
avoir
l' avantage d'être complètement ferait
donc c'est un peu pareil tu sors de la
prépa tu es bien mais en réalité le fait
de pas être rentré dans le match fait
qu'ils ont tous les deux chocs
bon là visuellement les blancs sont
beaucoup mieux mais il se trouve que
même la turbine est trouve l'égalité il
a joué quoi max ça va être ça en la
ligne claire qui ne jouent que pour la
news ici où il peut essayer de gagner
non tu joues que pour la nullissime s
est une belle prépare ainsi ça passe
c'est une très belle prépare car yakine
en vrai c'est si ça passe c'est bravo à
lui et ou à ses seconds ans parce que
comprendre et croirait pousser la ligne
et voir que c'est égal si réussi à le
faire
c'est très bien joué
si ça passait très bien joué et là le
truc en plus psychologiquement c'est
maxime le sait là c'est terrible quand
tu es en face parce que tu comprends tu
comprends
marlou en face
donc
donc donc la terrasse avec la berri
masquer le choix de merde de maxime
basse et son répertoire en fait il joue
rien d'autre sur 4,5
donc il a dû préparer aussi mais c'est
ce qu'alain créé profond de passer des
heures à faire une prépa qui a pour seul
but d'assurer là nul avec les noirs en
fait nul c'est un objectif qu'il assure
pas là nul il obtient là nul c'est très
bien joué
bizarrement c'est plus facile de planter
une prépa avec les noirs parce que c'est
plus les noirs qui amène où il veut
aller aux échecs
c'est contre intuitif mais en fait dans
les ouvertures à haut niveau c'est plus
les noirs qui peuvent décider où ils
vont et les blancs eux c'est un jeu de
devinettes en fait on va dire que dans
les prépas ce serait un peu comme un
penalty au foot ou les blancs c'est le
gardien et les noirs c'est le sait le
tireur je pense que maxime peut
comprendre qu'un électorat si c'est égal
oui ce moule pour la simple et bonne
raison qu'il sait que c'est vrai pas car
yakine ils le voient et carrier qingzhu
tempo donc il s'excuse tu comprends que
ça va être égal parce que c'est le truc
le plus logique avec les blancs et c'est
obligatoire que dans la variante la plus
logique car jaeckin et l'égalité donc
oui le comprends pas forcé de base pas
forcément mais en fait du coup tu
fouilles
tu cherches plus loin tu creuses et tu
finis par comprendre
c'est ou de faire une passe itunes ans
jusqu'au 16ème 17ème cours alors
celle-là jaussaud si elle va pas
jusqu'au 16ème 17ème un sale elle va
jusqu'au 25e en fait
le prêt sera également en ce moment mais
ça sent la nulle quand même cette partie
et baky du coup il ses pions plus mais
truc ultra théorique aussi fin et ultra
préparé avec activités pour les noirs
mais je préfère le truc de ba qui en
fait parce que son adversaire va devoir
trouver quelques coups pour s'assurer
l'égalité c'est ça a l'air d'être moins
linéaire que maxime après avoir la vie
peut changer en cours de route
ça c'est un avis à 14h50 après ça après
50 minutes de jeu
c'est l'impression que ça donne c'est
que maxime il s'est vraiment fait
prendre l'après ben carrier qui ne s'est
pas le même niveau que pure ou non
cariat qui n'ont ni sur un ex numéro
deux mondial khiroun on est sur un
palmarès de pure oud je veux résoudre
des problèmes aux échecs quoi le mec qui
est champion du monde de résolution de
problèmes fin c'est pas la même chose
donc c'est normal aussi mais mais avec
maxime nice et bien je crois qu'ici
c'est bien fait prendre donc le piège y
a pas de piège serions dit en fait la
carie qui n'y a pas de piège l'idée de
feria keynes est juste de faire nul en
fait y'a pas de piège c'est juste uva
dans un truc qui fait nul en force et tu
prends les blancs à la prochaine et
essaye de piéger avec les blancs et de
faire mal c'est la technique du penalty
là dans la plaie si on parle des prépas
ccar yakine le tireur ait eu thierry
cadre il marque et son idée au prochain
ça va être ça va être de savoir où
maxime veut l'emmener et de lui se
préparer sur ce que maxime s'est préparé
lui poser des problèmes
c'est vraiment c'est partir du bon côté
avec le gardien la maxime il est là il
se prend à contre-pied dans l'ouverture
maxime c'est cariat king qui mène la
danse et l'idée de karuïa keynes et avec
les blancs de mener la danse de nouveaux
savent qu'avec les blancs quand tu mènes
la danse tu gagnes en force
c'est ça l'idée j'ai passé facile à
comprendre pour vous pas j'essaye de
faire le de la manière la plus
imaginative
pourquoi pas
nul tout de suite alors déjà parce
qu'avec les blancs tu vas jamais accepté
c'est un aveu de faiblesse
et deuxièmement parce que dans son mas
est interdite avant le 30e ou donc là ça
va jouer je crois qu'il ya des ailles
laférois c8 donc c'est encore un autre
couture à nous avec la turbie moi je ne
suis pas sûr la turbine à jérémy roy au
8 mai le couceiro ac 8 prises prise
voilà je vous annonce que ces méga
analyser et on peut avoir une turbo
droit là ça peut être dur boudreau c'est
quand même les blanquillos initiative ça
c'est contre intuitif d'après ce que
vous n'êtes pas assez fort pour
comprendre aussi un sage peut que le
comprendre là on parle du très haut
niveau 1
d'ailleurs quand on regarde le sport à
la télé on nous explique pas alors tu
regardes le tennis it explique pas
vraiment les matches
là ils jouent tous tempo c'est sûr qu'il
a toutes analysées et le mec il va pas
toujours et mpo se lever à tous les
coups aussi la pas analysé jusqu'au bout
j'ai trois ça va être joué par maxime
très certainement et il veut partir
surtout racistes alors pourquoi il a pas
mille euros 8 ça m'aurait paru plus
logique
ces turbines de toute façon donc c'est
sûr que ce héros assez vite le coup on
n'y a même pas d'hésitation moi je
l'aurais mis à 8 mais ça doit 3 ses huit
lycéens
là il sait cariat qui n'ont ces
magnifiques prépare rien à dire là c'est
c'est travail d'orfèvre après il peut
encore se tromper plus tard faire des
erreurs maxime peu essayé de la jouer
mais je pense qu'il va vraiment réussira
à rentrer simplifiée
être déprimant de prendre un doute prépa
quand même ouais ouais non c'est ce qu
logiquement c'est relou mais des joueurs
du calibre de maxime savent très bien
gérer ces choses là
attendez je vais me remous juste
alors les amis est ce que on enverrait
pas les pubs on doit envoyer six minutes
de pub toutes les heures j'espère qu'on
va pouvoir faire deux fois trois minutes
d'affilée parce que j'ai vu qu'ils
avaient enlevés le 6 minutes
on va déjà envoyé trois minutes et on
verra si on peut renvoyer trois minutes
juste derrière dites moi si ça marche je
vois comment ça fonctionne
ces gens de 6,8 hors jeu complètement
d'accord avec toi mais voilà c'est pas
moi qui décide
six minutes aide moi si la pub marche ou
ça peut être 3 ça va être deux foix iii
je pense qu'elle va pas être là pour
tout le monde il ya des gens qui vont la
voir d'autres non je passe si vous
pouvez faire les marlous des andes
et les éviter donc
ouais ça va c'est 15 secondes ça va
c'est que ça n'a pas fonctionné mais ça
c'est là c'était un bug donc vérifier
que le raid est bien marché je vais
prendre un peu le temps après en fait on
est juste en première page switch en
réalité on a beaucoup moins de monde
qu'hier
c'est qu'on a beaucoup moins de monde
donc j'en sa femme a en fait il ya le
haut c'était tout ça hein c'est pas la
fête
mais clairement en fait mais même si
c'est même si on a les caméras
malheureusement en fait quand c'est pas
sur ma chaîne persona on a tout de suite
moins de monde c'est terrible justin
figuraient mais en fait faut enlever
4000 personnes due à la première page
twitter qu'on est plutôt 5000 en fait
sur ma chaîne on serait plutôt 8 8008
1500 mais c'est bizarre en fait le losc
n'a pas marché alors qu'il y ait très
bizarre mon nom je dirais que non mais
les autres jours c'était pareil même
même les jours y avait moins dangereux
et plus de monde
donc 1
jusqu'à mon anglais ouais mais parce que
là c'est nous qui avons moins de moins
de personnes organique
alors ces problématiques ce que je peut
pas renvoyer je vais voilà ça y est j'ai
réussi à faire la double pub à voir ce
que max fait mais honnêtement
honnêtement il va la probabilité de nu
lacé 90% en fait en fait assez 90%
d'euros
on va vite
c'est sur le président et je pense aussi
qu'on n'aura pas la cam du coup
une bonne situation ça drôle ouais pas
terrible pour maxime avec les blancs
mais après c'est pas grave non plus
arriver non mais peut lui faire la
réponse du berger à la bergère de man et
faire une huile rapide avec les noirs
j'espère qu'ils vont remplacer les
cadres et moi aussi on va voir
avantage je suis pas du tout sûr parce
que je pense à continuer à être
équilibré le truc c'est déjà car yakine
c'est un excellent joueur de rapides et
de blitz et en plus car acquise c'est
quelqu'un qui a un sang-froid
incomparable c'est quelqu'un qui est
très solide mentalement et du coup même
si la pression augmente la pression du
résultat augmente c'est quelqu'un qui
est censé ne ne pas ne pas craindre la
pression quoi
les ouvertures ça
à part comment va la carabine il avait
des lignes contre la berlinoise après il
a regardé quelque chose de plus précis
contre maxime alors il a joué je crois
que c'est fou j'ai trois et il s'est
levé
là ça pourrait être le premier moment où
karl et qu'il réfléchit c'est pour ça
que maxime s'est levé mais c'est
possible qu'ils connaissent encore un
nom il connaît tout raciste avec aria
kinky temps qui connaît veux pas
réfléchir
il réfléchit sur le temps de maxime ans
le vent il se rappelle de sa préférence
le vent ils jouent tous tempo pourraient
être maxime sous pression tempo tour à 6
non mais c'est les prépas c'est
insupportable c'est insupportable c'est
à dire que maxime la rivière déjà
dépensé une heure d'énergie à calculer
et il a pu prendre que quelques secondes
de repos en fait cercueil va se lever
cinq minutes il va lui rester 40 minutes
et c'est encore à lui de jouer fait il
te met la tête sous l'eau il te joue
tout tempo il te met la tête sous l'eau
hissbach retombe à 3,6 à jamais un tour
à 6 et sur celle mer ou en fait à tous
les coups vous car yakine c'est sûr que
c'est le meilleur coup à chaque fois
donc là on avait vu à 4 c'était coalisés
cet ours et si ces trois tours b6 est
sur b4 tour ses six tours des
trois-tours c4 et away c'était ça le
truc qu'on avait vu wayne on la tue pas
cela tu passes une journée un peu
difficile 1 et surtout raciste ourbih
store à 3 tours b6 des quatre peut-être
faire ces cinq du coût pour ces quatre
regarde un peu avec la turbine un pour
me faire un avis à six tours ces trois
rois 17
si on prend 4,38 la turbine est ok il ya
plein de petites fourmis afrique comme
ça et ça s'est mieux passé
salut femme ça va ça va et coûteux
il se passe pas grand chose là pour le
moment basse et prépare un attention
attention attention femme je le dépasse
il y avait par avions aussi un crime qui
était bien préparé c'est un peu complexe
c'est sur un environnement un petit peu
complexe
ouais ouais c'est le premier joueur de
haut niveau et c'est vrai que ça ça
confirme un peu fab ce dont on avait
peur en fait sur fin ce qui avait
peut-être un petit peu inquiété quizy
dans un casque couture est comme ça deux
minutes et tu repars à la plage comme tu
veux bon je veux que tu envoies le
casque akg vas-y
on doit attendre 20 ans
moi je mets pas le casque qu'est ce
qu'on voulait rester avec son micro
du coup est donc les grosses nouveautés
dans le manoir mais je pensais que
c'était ok c'était clair ça être une
berlinoise aujourd'hui ouais
frêche avait pas en fait du coup karekin
juste moi j'avais un doute savoir s'il
serait bien préparés ou pas les voilà à
faire c'est un mec sérieux de base mais
est semi retraite est un grand mot
maintient on devrait plutôt d'un gros
tournages ou simon s qui joue la coupe
du monde juste comme ça parce qu'ils en
russie et d amitié qui va jouer ou
est-ce que ce qui les prennent trop au
sérieux
on dirait que en fait j'ai dit ce que
j'ai c'est qu'il est un peu comme baky
ses terres en fête
retraité il choisit son tournoi mais
j'avais bien joué la cua est là il tente
donc oui en fait c'est clairement un
adversaire sérieux et redoutable
clairement le plus gros test pour maxime
jusqu'à présent parce que bon les autres
joueurs sans faire offense
enfin ces genres comme franc suisse à
l'euro tu peux perdre mais normalement
tu es heureuse hambourg était heureux or
ce tirage quoi donc donc façon c'est
bien passé quoi et carrier kink rail qui
nourrit non ça mais en plus sérieusement
j'ai l'argent de ce match c'est limite
décisif pour aller en finale
il imite une qualif pour les candidats
qua non mais plus pour qu'ariel chine
que pour maxime m'apprête à la chambre
cloud ide leur ayant donné un demi tête
quand même peut-être y reviens à mon
avis tu es freewin pour martirossian
mais en gros pour moi ça c'est le match
où j'ai fait un gros match là mais je
dirais que maxime il a quand même le
facteur pression qui peut
et puis l'a pas été impérial contre par
avion mais en travaillant je sais mais
bon après la mêlée aux autres tours
écoute on verra alors que cars yakine tu
vois je pense que c'est il a tellement
un sang froid alors c'est non mais
cesser ces trois rotations je suis pas
non mais c'est toi tranquille en fait en
éclats il ya trois rôles ou dans le
tchat
s'ils sont pas contents ils partent non
mais j'aurai la rigueur tu cliques alt
f4 banon mais préfère voir les regards
en plus j'aurais fait un cadrage royal
avec maxime engouement alors que tu as
comme ils mettaient maxime enfin on peut
il dès la cam un petit les commentateurs
en grand tournoi du coup j'ai changé les
noms ça n'intéresse pas je mets les
localiser en grand et les techniciens
ont petit ça peut l'être de la nasa qui
font bois et contre les fusées lancées
quoi donc
ouais bah qui s'est aussi préparée en
fait là je sais mais c'est peut-être
prépa maquis aussi ouais en fait je sais
que c'est ce truc tu gagnes un pion et
que c'est pas simple ya toujours du
contre jeu équilibré quoi mais bon
précis à seebach i garçons qui ont de
plus il va de sa petite finale il est
très heureux quoi ouais ouais je sai
baba qui en fait je sais pas peut-être
ça va être bien pour baky en vrai vaki
cia chance je pense que maxime c'est con
je commence déjà à me poser la question
est ce qu'il doit pas juste on les nuls
il doit y en avoir des centaines mais ce
qui doit pas juste faire gaffe en fait
pas bon enfin ne jeter moitié but de
retard et quand je regarde à 4 way
logique pour ces 6
ouais ces trois logiques way to b 6 les
quatre lignes du compte ce sont ces six
il revient autour des 3 tours c4 f3 ces
cinq hommes étaient déjà mal et tu peux
pas
ces quatre de ces trois en fait une
belle prestation lors des deux tours des
quatre en vrai je veux dire par là que
évidemment avec les blancs à mille et
une manières de faire nul c'est sûr en
fait quand on essaye vraiment garder
l'avantagé tous les coups les plus
logiques j'invite donc c'est les noirs
qui se retrouvent mieux non mais maxime
façon il est au courant du danger failli
voir notre jeu tout tempo donc là on ne
va pas aller dans un truc borderline
quoi ouais mais bon ça fait enfin tu
vois c'est je sais pas quel point c'est
facile ce camionneur qui réfléchit
michael carrick ils jouent tous tempo ya
un moment tu peux avoir une perte de
lucidité aussi je ne sais pas facile de
réfléchir aussi longtemps aussi
intensément neuf ça pour moi ça me
saoule rien au pire tu mets un coup tu
composes nul voila et tu peux pas
jusqu'au 30e a dit saad écoute foule
près pas bon ça dans un sens ou un autre
les jours après c'est aussi on va dire
que maxime il al avantage de jouer
toujours les mêmes ouverture et donc de
très bien connaître ses positions
mais du coup ses adversaires ils ont
l'avantagé de pouvoir le cibler de temps
enfin c'est un peu après 2o karim tu
veux la berline aux c'était pas une
surprise en jeu 5 6 ans que beaucourt en
quoi la vie maximum
non mais c'est une des raisons
personnelles mais ouais les turbines de
poutine ont peut-être tourner cette nuit
non mais il est vraiment proche de
poutine à caracas et plus quel poste il
a d'une commission qui a été créée par
poutine premier ministre et il a un truc
enfin et c'est jésus me rappelle plus du
nom de la commission mais tu as à une le
nom d'une gueule d'une commission
important tu vois ces genres pas une
commission cariat kinshasa c'est une
commission tu as tu as l'impression que
tu prends des des vraies décisions
et là il ya cariat kinky sièges non mais
tu vois il siège en vue dans un truc
important quoi tu penses que
c'est plus pertinent que les amis de
crown y avait quand même beaucoup plus
proche de poutine que cramique traduit
te dirai non le rock on garde a boy avec
rami qu'à côté ses vingt noms et
beaucoup beaucoup plus longue poutine
bader et des feuilles fait des
rencontres avec poutine karekin à la
télé et tout quand il était avant le
match contre carl ça y était venu dans
le bureau de poutine discuté tous les
deux tu vois quand il est revenu il
retourne discute avec poutine fin ils
discutent sous un régime syrien
non mais c'est comme si maxime l'avant
la coupe du monde orma gros tu vois un
petit peu et discutent dans l'elysée le
bureau machin position parce qu'il
repart à prêter une commission en france
je sais pas moi c'est maxime qui à la
fin là c'est karine pour la peine ouais
ils vont talent dernier mot en russie
comme une telle impression un peu pesé
quoi atteinte à un continent tu prends
des décisions quand même qui feint
secondaire et qu'il en fait
mais non mais peut-être qu'il a eue
putty le téléphone vladimir enfin
qu'est-ce que le joue quoi berlinois
stress au lit tu sais que j'étais à
berlin quand j'étais jeune vraiment très
fort bah je sais pas tu es vraiment un
mur entre parce que poutine et et en
allemagne compte à ok monsieur 1
du coup peut-être là il ya du foot
indoor à la berlinoise elle serait beau
en fait c'est une partie macro je crois
que vous connaît le vainqueur mais bon
j'ai peur c'est poutine qui a fait toute
la préparer non mais très clairement
karekin sûr qu'il a accès à des
ordinateurs très puissante façon la
fédération russe à des ordinateurs de
folie dans des genres de serveurs de fou
et c'est vrai que pour ce genre de prépa
ça peut être un avantage
envoyez des hackers faire la prépa
maxime est déjà bien de la chance de ne
pas avoir vu un test de pas avoir eu un
test pcr positif à mon avis avant la
partie donc ce banquet des étoiles à pas
de chance
ce serait beau éliminé voies de fait une
contre expertise mumbai ex bombay
normand fait du cou à toutes ces
questions donnant sa position en fait
bizarrement salaires logique pour les
blancs de sauver les pions à 4 ma chance
dit pas pourquoi dans leur zone kurde
mois mais a priori les turbines on dit
que ça va que ce tour c4 avec l'idée à
62,6 mail alors dit refais b5 tempo pour
ces trois baies quatre c4 c5 émissions
déjà toi qui va devoir faire avec les
faits en fait mais c'est ça le danger de
ces prépas en fait c'est que en fait ça
peut se retourner contre les blancs
c'est terrible en fait de penser que ça
peut se retourner contre toi la maca
socialement c'est moi quand je regardais
comme ça j'étais sur follow quoi j'ai
pas la turbine bon je vois que l'on joue
tout un beau je lis bon c'est sûr que
c'est bien des gens juste qu'il attend
de moi je suis pas trop pourquoi c'est
bien en fait non mais honnêtement c'est
ce que j'explique le chat c'est
incompréhensible que les noirs soient
pas moins bien c'est quasiment future
garde
plus tu as l'impression que c'est au
volant de faire gaffe dès que je mets un
peu lourdes ou quoi mais bon c'est oui
il faut juste plus chercher à gagner en
fait je veux faire nul tu feras nul mme
carlson en pls
ou alors ça c'est soit fourchette soit
un fou chat et du coup c'est band f soit
c'est vrai ok c'est pas ben dave parce
que ses avantages mais d'après la
turbine est donc il aura pas de bundle
jeu post une place mais bon si pink qu
il savait qu'il était très heureux un
jeu contre carl sanudi oui j'ai déjà
battu à bail que très bon appareil vendu
coup vraiment très comme savez contre
intel comme carafe scène je vais peut
jouer les pions pendant ma maman tu sais
pas je ne fais que jusqu'à 26,5 entrées
contre intel comme lui je fais ed vous
allez voir l'avantagé la pulsion pendu
on me mathieu nault d'ici que -0 08 / c
c est quand même mais bon bah du coup
c'est bien moins de ventes avec les noms
je suis content et super content que
c'est bien sortie de l'ouverture et baky
ça joue pas après c'est mieux que les
candidats a commenté à suivre parce que
y'a que 38 de rajouts 40e malgré ça oui
voilà c'est ou attire maxime va jouer
trois qui l'a fait à quatre passes et
plus ou moins logique quoi donc c'est
quoi ces tours revient c'est 6 donc on
attendrait on va le voir arriver je
pensais à cuatro il a joué c'est sur ces
bons qui me faire son retour karekin en
tête du concours de marche a aujourd'hui
fait mal à la concurrence et du coup il
ya un fond violet derrière maxime du
bouscarret keane qui a pris la tête du
concours de marche alors je m'en vais
mais il s'est élevé dé des grecs
seraient fichés partie ça fait une heure
qui marche comme jamais depuis 14h05 il
marche et il sait jamais réussir il est
venu il ne tempo ils marchent pas et
d'ailleurs la regarde il utilise son
temps il va peut-être venir que quand il
restera 45 minutes un litre le dollar il
revient à peine maintenant et on regarde
il revient vite en bas je pense qu'il va
jouer tempo il va retrouver marché a
chuté
regarde ça se sent ayvaz il va jouer
gatti chic et on dirait un achat n ont
hélas il joue la regarde je retourne
marché pour ses six frères disparus
il va se barrer absente à néant mais je
retourne je ne prend pas de retard
à l'échelle des choses c'est comme au
tennis entre les jeux quoi c'est sa
petite pause fraîcheur il se repose du
concours de marchands faty c'est ça en
fait il reste un petit peu assis pour
récupérer ok mais peut-être qu'il
comprend que sa prépa elle va pas
beaucoup plus loin et qui doit commencer
à réfléchir
mais en fin de compte se faire qu'après
pas jusqu'à robot futur - ou tout
bloquer ou enfin tu peux pas test voulu
rejouer tempo encore après mais la prépa
est vraiment impressionnante calment
1 0 c'est une des grandes lignes de la
berline aux entourages six matches c'est
pas une petite variante se chercher des
daara les fagots c'est peut-être que
révolutionne complètement un truc gros
quoi une partie bas ou peut-être
vraiment ferme le truc ça rappelle ce
qui explique et là ils ont les années 90
les années 90 se trouvait une nouveauté
une nouvelle idée d'utiliser vos moins
six mois
oui et il me dit contre les joueurs à
moins de 2005 c'était vraiment le temps
qu'ils y à un livre qui sort qu'ils
apprennent un peu beaucoup même une fois
qu'ils ont appris tu sais pas miss monde
et l inde et l
mais en fait maintenant la nouveauté à
la 15e minute plus large ou pas juste
après en fait tu l'as déjà l'annexion de
chez ce point comme en train de faire
des huit ils sont déjà en train de faire
faire si jamais des open avec des rondes
à 18h tu peux te prendre le troc est
allé vraiment bah oui je sais c'est
terrible alors qu'avant je veux dire
c'est comme genre le truc que du boeuf
fait contre kaia qui n'assure
l'italienne jouer tous déjà par sa fin
et j'ai déjà cuits savez quoi valdes
avait toujours su par contre il savait
on se passe pour baky bas et coûte un
bras qui s'est équilibré mais qui en
vaut pas qui peut gagner voilà c'est ça
ou frères nul très vite mes mails et pas
du tout en danger
max est en fait s'il va faire nul très
vite mais il met pas du tout de pression
sur son adversaire en fait
la coupe du monde fab non au long de
l'année enfin est ce que tu as été
proche de nom mais en fait j'ai même pas
fait venir d'europe pour lequel j'ai
fait un championnat d'europe champion
que 2011 peut être avec slim ben j'ai
pas menacée moins qualifiés et c'est
tout en fait c'est hyper dur européen
aurait peut-être que tu attends t'es là
encore eh ouais je me fait naturaliser
change de pays respectait encore et tu
t'entends un match plein fouet
enfin j'ai pas coréens ou d'autres pays
quoi mais ouais tomber système et ouais
les européens pour se qualifier c'est
hyper tendu vers le chemin d'europe et
finir un top-20 quoi thomas hyper fort
mais c'est arrivé inséré en tout elle
pourrait en plus c'est la ligne que j'ai
montré la toute première salle à ya
toujours un coup logiquement fait jouer
que les coûts normaux avec les blancs et
je répondais de turbine est avec les
droits un est peut-être tourner nos du
koala par ailleurs sur le coup turbine à
très faible et catherine tu te prends
les c5 pas satisfait ses 5 6 4 et deux
blocs l'autre je sais pas fessé 5-1 mais
ah bon
1 ce sont bien des chances ou pas du
tout et ça sera en fait si tu veux tout
parfait avec les blancs il ya des
chances est dur à dire c'était parti qui
sont très difficiles à analyser à
expliquer parce qu'en fait c'est fin
personne c'est vous et bien même maxime
sais pas et en fait c'est même pas
possible d'expliquer parce qu'on peut
pas vous dire oui c'est très bon coup
pour les noirs ou quoi en vrai si
c'était pas analysé à la maison ce que
fait car hacking c'est catastrophique
oui georges était pas préparé au liban
il est un pur - est-ce que maxime va
transformer mais le truc c'est que bon
on va pas dire ça puisqu'on sait que
c'est probablement tous les meilleurs
coups fondamentaux qu il en train de
jouer juste c'est impossible à
comprendre parce que les échecs c'est
pas un jeu dogmatique si ça marche ça
marche en fait c'est tout ouais mais
c'est en fait à priori jouer une finale
dans un tournoi c'est tout ce qu'on dit
de pas faire quoi vous perdez un pion
garder les pièces pour compliquer balle
à lui n'ont été change tout jeune finale
l'option de - très puis là en plus j'ai
envie de te dire est ce qu'au niveau du
temps vu qu'il ya que 30 minutes de
rajouts aurait pas tant parce que ça
peut être important
en fait même si tu arrives à a joué sans
gros design jusqu'au 40e tu vas être en
fait tu vas tellement souffrir
physiquement dans la partie insulaire tu
te fatigues quand même là à jouer enfin
jouer de calculer trois heures d'affilée
c'est dur légende ou clôture rouge tempo
c'est en fait du liant les parties
longues nature des temps forts temps
faibles et des repos pendant que l'autre
est réfléchie du fait de ballades et tu
commences à autre chose et quand c'est
tout le temps à toi de jouer
bah oui tu fais quoi fleischer c'est
pourtant magie en fait là si tu te
retrouves en premier dès ait quand tu as
joué tempo carillo 42e coup ils font
encore toy boys ou encore wallon
rapidement ce qui calcule sur ton temps
et que toi il te reste 10 minutes que la
finale elle est chaude et que tu viens
de passer deux heures cinquante à
calculer non-stop mata ce juste que tu
craques parce que tu peux plus quoi
c'est pas comme si comme tu disais tu
avais des dépenses et 2h50 mais l'autre
au 6 août a eu des temps de pause ans de
pause et on sait en plus que maxime
c'est pas forcément son point fort après
s'être concentré à fond tout le temps
maximus quelqu'un qui calcule très bien
très vite très loin mais qu'il n'y a pas
une autonomie aussi longue qu'un un
caruana ou qui incarne scène elle n'a
pas les piles duracell padura stalder du
coup ça
peut être ça peut revenir rentrer dans
l'équation car yakine ça parce qu'ils le
savent un ici connaissent leurs points
forts et leurs points faibles
ça peut rentrer dans cette équation
qu'elle soit refait déjà fait un truc
similaire il prenait vachement de temps
alors qu'il connaissait en tout temps
qu'auraient meka soir en fait y il
prenait son temps que tu étais pas
rentrer dans la variante où il allait se
terminer et diktats a dévié de la paire
de créoles et à perdre je sais pas
encore
j'y réfléchis une heure mais maintenant
que tu as tu manges tu as perdu je
souhaitais me faisait il le faisait
carif île mais bien une leçon cinéma
[Musique]
monde je la remets machin compliqué tu
t'es trompé de fait abandonnées d'air
mais ça on le fait plus trop maintenant
parce que déjà ça marche moins bien et
en plus on a quand même besoin de garder
le temps parce qu'ils défendent mieux
aussi les gens maintenant non puis
peut-être aussi on est moins naïfs
affaire tout est de marc loterie et ya
quand même les vols qui le fait encore
mario des en 2008 fait donc sans savoir
s'ils veulent ils jouent tempo lors du
très populaire jeu s'est délité maison
je connaissais pas il se marque mais
c'est bien ça ouais 1,5 c'est chiant
quand tu crois que l'autre a pu analyser
cette man ps enfin sauf peut-être et
confiance je t'aime bien analyser tous
mais quand tu sais pas tu me dis [ __ ]
les anti jo ratu suit partout bah c'est
malin lemond mais bon le truc segment
ils savent qu'ils peuvent le faire aussi
mais c'est quand même mon père s ouais
mais bon mais le truc c'est que du coup
quand il le fait et qui bloque passé
d'autres je pensais que c'est de la
merde c'est gbagbo a maintenant fait et
a défoncé des portes marlou stépane
prépa pour moi en plus j'ai eu un peu de
chance je fais dans une variante c'est
justement peux pas me prendre de prépa
éviter en fait l effet ne crée pas
monter le cas d'autres qui pouvaient
peut-être jouer ça il ya quelques mois
est écornée toi non pas du tout en 2005
j'avais déjà préparé il ya 16 ans
championne 11
de temps pour mener cette terrible et
d'après mes analyses au 34e cook a fait
une imprécision n'est pas fou d2 c'était
fou ces trois importants s'il y avait
une nuance au 44e
il ya par exemple est justement taf ou
des malfaiteurs mais dur à comprendre
sans vie dure à comprendre c'est
d'ailleurs ça a été rejoué une quelques
années plus tard des 4 b c soit à leur
nom pour ces six tours des trois-tours
c4 celle avant tout je disais que ça
pouvait être chiant en fait c'est
marrant parce que maxime je vous jure
enfin les gens ont vu donc ils ont vu
mais toi je t'assure que c'est le
premier truc que j'ai regardé genre
après cavaliers des quatre temps qu'il
ya quand même un moment il ya une heure
de ça j'ai montré cette position ce que
ça me paraissait le truc le plus logique
en fait mais maxi je pense pas qu'il va
faire et froid il va faire un tour f3
peut-être dont j'ai quatre courts et vii
c'est plutôt salées sont 17 métro sur un
peintre est moins mais ça pourquoi ce
serait pas mieux pour les blancs quand
même par contre avec le c5 à leroy est
tellement fort en réussissant fait rage
commence à comprendre en fait toi tu vas
voir les c5 talent pur ici pas atterri
talent pur avec les pièces blanches
est ce que tu peux pas tus même moins
bien qu'en fait si de fait ces cinq
bouffe bouffe qui bouffe à 4 7 6 aux
roms et leurs pions bosseur mais
assailli fait semblant de réfléchir pour
la première fois qui a pas joué le coup
et mes rôles lors d'une très faible b4
mais c'est pas cool numéro 1 b 4 2 à
tours 2-2 ouais
arkane et c5 et c6 est plus exact
rivière la meilleure façon pour ces 6 tu
trouves bas mais ce que t'as pas envie
de faire ces cinq mais c'est simple a
pas peur de tours c'est quoi trop
souvent non mais j'aime mieux le ton
tour c'est son nom mais j'essaye de
réfléchir aussi bercy réfléchit je me
demande encore qu'en fait l'inconvénient
du tour c'est enfin une tour ses six
tours c4 pour garder en fait le tour des
trois tours est la tour f 7 mais bon
sens tu voir wade cette réussite eu ça
tout seul non mais ça je pensais même
trouvable sur l'échiquier
alors niveau oui mais jugé enfin des
fois tu te moques la nation oui oui bien
sûr mais en vrai ce que c'est pas ça
paraît fou ce que je vais dire mais ce
que c'est pas mieux pour les noirs genre
si tu prends tout le pas que la position
mais si tu prends genre tout la
situation de la partie le temps la
fatigue la prépa est-ce que genre tu
préfères pas être cardiaque initie on va
peut-être en votre page plus surtout si
tu sais les coûts bon là il sait plus
oui tente de se remémore m
ouais je pense que c'est plus parce
qu'en fait il se remémore depuis tout à
l'heure je pense qu'il a plus non c'est
plus dans son daniel
bien loin du cercle noir sont mieux
après je dis pas les noirs fin comme je
disais je prends pas que la situation de
l'échiquier je prends l'échiquier la
pendule et le côté psychologique pour
essayer de faire une évaluation globale
parce que c'est les échecs c'est quand
même deux êtres humains qui vous l'un
contre l'autre c'est pas deux turbines
msi ou quoi tu vois il ya tout le côté
psychologique qui rentre en compte et je
me demande si contenu prend tout c'est
pas maxime qui est un peu du mauvais
coup tu fais un mauvais côté de la nuit
ça va pas être micropousses est noir
après bon pour le moment je pense pas
qu'ils aient grand danger un sociaux
parce que demain terrible on est mais ça
on en parfum c'est vraiment que en
prenant là le truc d'aujourd'hui dans
une liste demain ils allaient blanc
arrive l'histoire puis c'est pas super
moi j'ai peur du pu empoisonner dans la
nage dans le flou
mais je pense que maxime évitera parce
que vu la gueule de la prépa check-in
aujourd'hui ouais mais peut-être enfin
en fait je sais pas ce qu un qui ne
serait prêt pour ce tournoi où si genre
ça c'est un truc il a pu faire pour
carlson à l'époque il car ça n'a jamais
rentré dedans et ba ba du coup tu l'as
toujours eu ouais mais le truc c'est
qu'il a tout les prépas roscoff
donc il peut avoir des fichiers dans
deux chroniques ambulants ils appellent
ils appellent poutine poutine et appelle
kramnik la prépa poutine il a dit je
veux pas donner mais prépa poutine c'est
évident mais c'est passé pas une
question donne la prépa sais pas je veux
où je veux pas si tu donnes la prépa tu
vois je trouve t'elle pas laisser cela
prépa va être donné quoi c'est bon ça va
cuire voilà tu veux arrêter tout était
tournoi son rauque et frérot un tu vas
plus rauque et mais pour d'autres
raisons n'étaient pas bien un petit va
recevoir l'appel du président de la
russie abbaoui improbablement d'ailleurs
c'est beau cette magie alors si ça
marche vraiment comme ça j'en où on est
en haut tu délires mais en fait pour de
vrai fort cramique refuse on va te
rappeler dans 5000 t'inquiète pas tu vas
très bientôt accepter qu'ils ne veulent
voir sonner
oui bonjour je me présente l'adil
routine de téléphone on m'a dit que tu
avais reçu les données une prépa je sais
pas j'ai eu des échos le travail à temps
complet
il a fait autour des trous tu peux
refuser de redonner un peu près fait
très attention à ce que tu vas manger ce
soir très attention au problème ce n'est
pas obligatoire mais on a pré pas mais
bon c'est recommandé quand même je veux
pas faire de ta vie mais c'est beaucoup
c'est la russe qui vont qui vont raquer
tous les fichiers de mac si
extraordinaire sa joie il a fait tourner
ses six tours neutre et ours est ancien
mais c'est pour vince est en avance ou y
avait eu une heure comme un oeuf
mais j'étais pas content quand j'ai vu
ça j'ai dit maxime ne va pas jouer parce
que je la sentais pas un 12-0 faut pas
faire le f3 le plein de couvron d'après
la turbine jarlet tour f3 pour les
prendre et 7 pas dire wager de propre il
y plein de trucs mais f3 qui défend bien
attaqué non je pense que la ligne que de
fin mais ça ça me fait vraiment peur en
fait mais ça en fait je pense c'est mon
genre de truc qui comprend maxime de ces
dynamiques weiner un truc qu'il aimerait
bien faire acteur mais justement est-ce
que des fois c'est pas pire c'est comme
parfois les bons à très bons défenseurs
comme baky sont pas de bons attaquants
commence à se mettre en pls de tout un
jeu c'est pas non mais ça fait un peu
enfin je sais pas moi je suis en perez
totale avec les blancs ici non mais
c'est s'est réfusé 1
or voilà fusée ça sera trouvé mais non
plus tu as 25 minutes est au fond du
trou et crever l'autre entre nice et je
serai hyper énervé quoi tu balances
réglo sur la gueule j'ai pas fait exprès
a glissé
et c'est bon quoi pourquoi c'est le
fameux c5 non en fait ça attaque b4 en
force et une fois que l'option b 4 il
dégage pas ça à perdre et à 4 et puis et
puis voilà quoi après pas bon je sais
pas ça peut se tenir mais l'argent n'a
plus de tours de plus
et puis on passait à le roi n'aura eu du
bon côté il va monter en fait le 3
contre 2 il bouge plus il est bloqué en
fait c'est ses pions là ça c'est
important de le montrer en fait ça ça
bouge pas du coup ça ça bouge pas ça ça
bouge pas diallo kling et ça ça bouge en
fait virtuellement les noirs ont pas
tout à fait un pion de plus mais on
comprend que c'est eux qui poussent
alors majorité qui bouge
maxime il a fait tous rêvent trois roues
à 17 ans très exactement dans le truc il
va peut-être pendant ces 3 l'enfoiré
plus dangereux parce qu'en fait tu vas
tu un étudiant qui on prends mais tu
auras des pions passé mais bon ouais
mais tu aurais dû contre sochaux
moi j'aurais plutôt pris j'ai calmé il
joue assez vite maxime en fait là cette
soirée apple a ravi nantes
à l'inversé des choix pas simple à faire
voilà c'est gros choix pour carrier
keane vase est ce que tu oublies 4 ou c3
en photo après droit de faire re aussi
si tu as envie ça changera pas la
namibie 3 et 6 il fait très froid table
alors prévu qu'un choix à mais d'un
autre côté si tu fais roi gk3 aussi s'il
aurait pu partir en achète donc en vrai
si tu dois vraiment décider si tu
décides de prendre gk tu commences par
réussissent et surtout racheta tu gardes
le choix sinon tu prends ces trois
puisque maxime est perdant non pas du
tout avec les plantes et pas très
content quoi du scénario on va voir un
peu bas qui on sera sûr qu'ils aient un
coup et demi de jouer quoi ils
s'incrustent 88ème il va presser pâquis
ouais je reconnais sa vie va essayer un
petit peu baissé un peu nan on va rester
c'est sans maxime en plus on la réclame
sur lequel tous nos espoirs sont quand
même fondé après pas qui bat qui peut y
aller aux candidats et à 3 matches à
gagner
il est favori contre pur ou non au match
ben il est un grand oui un test pcr
positif des candidats ces forums est ce
que max est ce que magnus a vraiment
envie de jouer compact a déjà il est pas
favori quand sylvain go way après non
mais géré cette image in magnus bon il
perd contre baky c'est pour nous c'est
alors résultat logique voilà on sait
mais tu as aux yeux du monde entier et
en norvège lille c'est la révélation
après de rudes combats qui est là les
mecs vont se rendre compte à wim et le
mec est plus fort que ma guise depuis
déjà quinze ans on nous a menti c'est
infondé a vendu un champion du monde qui
a toujours été derrière baky quoi donc
c'est vrai que ça tu as ça peut être ça
le mensonge peut éclater le voile peut
se lever aux yeux du monde entier quoi
bas qui est le meilleur joueur du monde
un test positif des candidats vraie
question
napper n'est pas au top niveau il y a
été âpre elle a perdu un match de
championnat du monde qu'il a été très
proche de perdre contre plus de gagner
pardon contre car le sel et après il a
peut-être eu un moment de démotivation
quoi oui oui oui car à quesnoy lava
finale du championnat du monde quand
même
c'est le haut niveau au pyla mais je
sais pas il ya toujours de 1757
donc c'est pas si mal faire un truc
désolé les amis
on va voir oui non c'est vrai que le
match de carling comme ça n'en fait cai
qui ne mène au score dans le match et il
ya un partout en fait sur les douze
parties i et en plus la partie hyper il
rate une répétition
oui n'était pas si simple puisque et
après même dans les départage autant que
rona s'est fait marcher dessus 3 0
autant qu'à et qui n'est qu'on sépare
nul revenus les après et perdu les deux
dernières il a vraiment mis une
résistance incroyable quoi alors qu'à
voir le match je voudrais se défoncer et
après les heures ou jours il a une
petite baisse de régime
ouais bah des motivations c'était un peu
la chance de ta vie bon en fait il a
tout fait pour
il peut même pas de l'issue de son match
il a vraiment bien fin mai mais est donc
peut-être ceni je serai pas champion du
monde c'est comme ça il un peu relâché
mais je sais pas enfin mais à cela qu'il
a toujours été sa grande force c'était
la force montagne quoi être toujours là
dans les moments importants alors il
continue était derrière au score et
revenant dans les matches quand il a
gagné sa coupe du monde
on dit de lui qu'il était mené 20
c'était une finale en quatre parties il
est quand même mené 2-0 quoi tu dois
faire
deux sur deux dont une victoire avec les
noirs c'est pas gagné d'avancé et il l'a
fait et après la grogne il est rapide
c'est pour ça quand on me disait ce que
maxime est favori en rapide il a ils
auraient raison de faire deux nuls
le truc c'est qu'un carré qu'il est
tellement fort dans la tête que en fait
même si maxime est un peu plus fort
intrinsèquement aujourd'hui en rapide en
blitz quand tu vas arriver en 1805 +3
maxime sabo est top 3 mondial tu vas
être dans un must win est là car yakine
il a le sang froid et en plus il est bon
en biscaye qui n'en fait elle était
champion du monde 2006 je le rappelle a
encore été exceptionnel avec vlad
cela ne me dit rien qui n'ait et quand
même complètement nuls on glisse et moi
je voulais quand même champion du monde
en titre ils than me répond ah je ne
savais pas du coup ça m'a surpris et
très surpris comment intel a pu gagner
mais non c'est un très bon ben ça est
vrai nom mais bien sûr c'est le match
chaud quoi enfin mais il a refait son
coup d'être menés de revenir contre et
si bing contre artemiev largement oui
oui les 2 nuls et hyper le premier
rapide et il te refais la victoire quand
il doit faire pour égaliser mais il n'y
a pas perdu ce côté là peut-être l'idée
de maxime c'est tour j'ai quatre tours h
si c'est ce que tu peux faire nul enfin
si je crois trois des sept tours âge
cette même lettonie 3 tu donnes ton film
est enfermé à toronto ranger 3 à 8 ans
elle est enfermée vrai tour g4 à j-6
romont tourne vraiment plus toi tu
redescends et tout réussissait aux
quêtes et c'est ça qui l'a trouvée
maxime en vrai je sais pas
siva c'est dans le règne de maxam un
visa il va trop fins et mais je pense
qu'il veut plus que ça maxime ou
cardiaque à maxime baca qui sait que
votre carrière je pense qu'il sait qu'il
doit faire nul et que si jamais l autre
fait dire c'est trop mais battue va
contrer mais qu en soit la moria nul à
bath
c'est ce que tu es venu chercher la
mosquée mais aussi faire tourner en c3
mais en fait c'est dur de voir mieux en
fait avec les lenteurs patron et le fils
et b4 le sait tous pousser ça m'effraie
jurés frayer g6 va faire tour c4 en plus
maintenant ils te prend partout et ils
poussent vite ans ils poussent plus vite
que toi le roi est trop fort tu attends
ça joue ça vous il a fait tout reprend
ses droits ou pas je vérifie jusqu'à il
ya déjà eu des bas qu'ici et maintenant
ça tranche le voit sur l'écran mais sa
vie retirée qu'il joue tient en fait
mais tu peux lui faire une tour atx
histoire je sans toi ma lampe torche 6-3
la tourache est fou qu'ont vécu et leur
dit a beau être content de tours g7
mais ce me contente jet tours c'est un
fou des deux humainement
bientôt important ok du coup ça va parce
que si tu gagnes g5 tu pousses f après
bon donc tout rachat 3,6 peut-être mais
il faut que devront faire et c'est la
même rsa peut faire drôle mon fable plus
et du coup 30 devront alors être opposé
à l'enppi bon là de façon sénile pas
répète oui oui oui il était 5 ou 10 ou
maxime là il est pas en position de
parme imprécis joue des mauvais coups il
peut perdre et on va dire qu'il est
peut-être obligé avec les blondes
accepté 30 l'annulent quoi qu'est-ce qui
est pas très grave en soi même
une pub mais faut bien que je mette les
six minutes mais alors je les ai mises
j'espère que ça va fonctionner mes amis
les six minutes la première est prévue
en avance non non j'ai déjà un réveil en
fait à 55 pour mettre deux fois trois
minutes
la foire le génie pour la gagne mais en
fait c'était pas obligés de la gagner à
vrai dire non on va te lire france nul
en soit c'est normal comme demain ce
serait normal aussi en fait mais c'est
toujours j'étais attendu en fait on va
dire nul entre deux joueurs à peu près
du même niveau haut niveau ils ont à peu
près le même niveau la maxime est
cardiaque
surtout dans ce format je dirais dans un
tournoi et où maxime peut-être un peu
plus formés dans ce format non l'instant
son mari incarné chien il est bon tous
les candidats et les a bien joué et les
coupes du monde il ya beaucoup d'enjeu
il est plus fort qu'un élève son niveau
de jeu avec l'enjeu c'est un grand
joueur c'est la marque des grands
joueurs
donc ça et baki n'a rien cassé quatre
bons temps c'est logique il en a trop et
faisait rien donc cela ramène un peu
plus son jeu plus centralisée ouais ça
va jouer mais je pense qu etienne il
peut presser après faut voir avec trois
tours eux deux quand même peut-être tu
peux récupérer d'enfance en france
autour de ça reste dans le temps de
regarder toute façon y'a vert perdant
non pas du tout ce toit avec les
évaluations frère non ça va a besoin de
nouvelles vertus contre ya toujours un
point de plus après oui blaye et des
compensations visuel quoi cercle ou de
maximy n'est cloisonné le roi adverse
il n'est pas mal en russie et 5 ok
surprise il enlève le pion des cases
noires mais en fait il fait pas là nul
qu'on attende avec la tour qui attend
ses quatre peut-être faire tout ça
recommencera des cinq tours h7
mais bon
un territoire mais bon page 1 100 faut
pas trop non plus chercher midi à
quatorze heures quand tu peux faire pour
ces quatre thèmes ponant en plus il
continue à tout jouer tel pour en fait
et tour affiche 3 des 5 alors peut-être
nul ouais nan là ça sent la nulle et
toura ouais ça revient ok bon ben voilà
turbo d'euros ouais chariati
l'incroyable ans nue dans la maison y
n'essaye même pas de la gagner et draw
termine à dos ok bon no more the web à
une partie typique du haut niveau aux
échecs en fait prépa parti jouer à la
maison en fait voilà à un parent
cardiaque et un maximum
il a joué sur l'échiquier m mais bon en
gros tu joues contre la meilleure que la
position où nul ne peut rien y faire
mais là c'était parti parti jouer à la
maison
et côté bakewell bayer le fou prend et
froide pour eux deux dont on parle est
bon il faut preuve de sa gaine le pion
bras bout je t'en prends tous reçurent
par électrophorèse de bon là aussi je
mettrais cette formule quoi ah ouais ça
va être deux sur vos droits aujourd'hui
aux basses et dimanche ils veulent qu'on
se repose en fait parce que j'annonce
directement ont su que les françaises et
les français puisque la compétition est
longue et un beau but du pousseur était
compliquée pendant je crois que ça dure
ça hier 27 jours ou 28 jours d'affilée
de suivre toutes les parties tout le
temps va être juste au bout d'un moment
et faire les résumés les machins et tout
c'est juste pas pas faisable
jusqu'à maintenant on est resté plutôt
longtemps parce que les français ont
joué tous les jours et des parties
longues à chaque fois mais donc si un
jour ça joue un peu moins on va en
profiter pour la plage oui voilà plage
va tomber un break les lans par loubards
fait de base quant à des plantes c'est
de gagner mais qu'on disait un nul c'est
plus ou moins
hic c'est dur de gagner en fait c'est en
fait
quant à les blancs ont des mecs moins
fort que toi quand tu nous tiens 450
points de moins tu as une grosse
différence
jean-maxime il va faire un gros score en
général entre condé je retourne de 1600
à quitter les blancs parce qu'elle a des
mais après pas évaluer des positions
tranchante qui lui correspondait il va
imposer son style et il devrait gagner
souvent cantal et noir témoin là dedans
quoi voilà mes mais après quand je vois
quelqu'un d'autre qui est aussi bien
préparé que toi des fois plus des fois
un peu moins bien ça dépend des jours
mais voilà en général peu près pareil
bah tu fais moins cette différence là
donc nul logique quoi fatiguer de gagner
en temps quand tu peux enfin je fais ton
truc savent pas tu avais pas et est rien
de mal en fait les basterds et sait pas
c'est loin d'être une catastrophe a
l'impression que la vie n'est plus là nu
les plus communes ah oui largement
peut-être 80% du temps quoi enfin je
sais pas j'ai pas les stats en tête
alors j'ai envoyé la cam banon et de
saint jean les cheveux gris noir fait
dos non il a les blancs ce chant claqué
pousser sa barbe celui de la 7e et gris
non mais là les blancs aux finances a
peut être qui s'était si vite que c'est
pas duda c'est pas dur à bari repartir
aux y en a chez madoff non c'est pas ici
bingo km2 ont acquis à la 6e place et si
bien qu il est là
chopin ou plutôt non cespedes s'est fait
d'os avait fait escale et blanc est fait
d'acier beach ça va merci qui est
l'autre c'est la chante là qui a changé
c'est peut-être lui donne change
il faut pousser la barbe et tout cas
rien de rien ça aussi c'est la chante la
prendre car ils sont quand même
tellement c'est un cd gopro qua non mais
c'est elecam c'est quand même terrible
hein l'éclairage et la colo mettriez
tous et c'est clair on la chante là non
sachant que là c'est ce qu'ils nous
disent
il fait un bon petit tournoi
enfin je sais pas trop si la fédé et
recrutement restent dans les deux
parties comptent djoumabaïev superman
mais il parie bassoka ma chance mais il
doit s'ériger pas encore être champion
du monde d'échecs s'est cramé il avait
dit je joue pour être champion du monde
juif et que toi en fait c'est pas dit
croire en fait ça donne un objectif mais
bon il y convier à sa position vers
désabusé un peu voire très bien avec
structure d'options vraiment très
intéressante
et du coup mourinho risque bas qui n' ya
pas de cave 1 sur baky c'est un problème
ça parce que cette câble en fait ils
vont pas la déplacer
c'est vers ça ouais les autres c'est ça
et après c'est le tournoi filles 1
un des techniciens bas ce sont ces
tournois fille après katja
enfin peu importe un ouais je checke si
jamais un baky ambulants mais on n'aura
pas pas qui je crois a pris il rate le
nordmann vraiment je faisais pas bien
sont ils ratent le favori du tournoi
l'emporter enfin madina peu importe on
va laisser magnus du coup bizarre quand
je suis en train comme ça d'avoir aussi
peu de caméras surtout comme jc des
caméras fixes a battu voilà on s'est pas
failli avait pas de caméra ou quoi enfin
y'a personne qui met la patate en master
chaque bac arrive en finale il n'y aura
aucune caméra brolin non mais c'est
quand même dommage
sadate qui peuvent pas filmer le fantôme
quoi ouais c'était la théorie on n'a pas
à l'échiquier bien cadré enfin 2000
colonne une colonne ça change pas grand
chose à la position malheureusement
[Rires]
c'est le premier jour il se passe
r en fait c'est pour bien m'accueillir
quoi mais tu vois c'est pas des pinces
et pas des parties intéressantes à dire
n'ai rien à dire vraiment y'a rien à
dire c'est parti on fera un petit résumé
du coup bon gardien direction du but
fra oui voilà nouveautés vous les
turbines de poutine de vlad la boys ont
tourné torse nu sur la canebière voilà
bah oui mais voilà torse nu sur la
canebière torse nu à sauter putty hill à
sa maison sa grande baraque sa sortie
c'est à domicile que ce n'est pas une
entrée tranquille serait pas besoin
championnat du monde en fait il est
qualifié le seul joueur qualifié qui
joue ses cartes c'est moi je trouve ça
complètement anormal mais après les gens
m'explique dans le chat que c'est normal
bah non mais enfin problème c'est que
c'est mal fait leur truc
pas sûr
on doit pas donner de place c'est juste
une coupe du monde que j'ai celui-ci
doit se déplacer du coup c'est fait
c'est dégueulasse je suis comme ça ne te
faire éliminer en retard une chanson ou
quelqu'un d'autre parce qu'il est battre
s'appelle manuel je garde ça me garde de
basse quoi tu préfères veut quelqu'un
d'autre un peu moins bien classés un peu
moins il fait moins peur après ce très
beau pays si peamcoal élimine maintenant
puisque enfin pour les quarts de finale
il ya des places au grand prix donc
c'est là qu'il faut vraiment la
compétition
c'est à partir de maintenant qu'il faut
c'est vraiment donc ça bien qu'il se
fasse sortir maintenant histoire qu'il
ait rien foséco afin qu elle est nulle
et une fausse quoi d'après moi ce que je
disais en fait j'aurais été pour qu'ils
jouent si tu risques de perdre son titre
de champion du monde mais tu te
qualifies pas tu ne sais pas finalement
même si tu te qualifies pas pour aller
prendre le titre de champion du monde
pourquoi tu lui en fait donc coup d'oeil
au moins c'est chevaleresque jusqu'au
bout il doit faire tous les tournants du
coup bah oui me faire violence et gagner
celui-là il joue pas les autres mais
mais il doit faire local fille natif et
s'ils se qualifient pas les deux fois on
va tromper attendait pas de chance
fallait pas venir c'est pas si grave en
fait ça arrive mais en fait si tu
essayes de te qualifier du coup et tu te
qualifies pas c'est pourquoi des
champions en fait pas si tu es champion
parce que tu es protégés que t'as pas le
choix les tournois mais c'est juste que
tu es un prix était privilégiée en fait
cette pelouse du champion depuis
toujours là du coup qui joue la carte
zen contenait pas c'était les toits des
candidats enfin je sais pas si tu étais
là soyaux pour le coup mais c'est le
tournant a quand même qui était grande à
commenter il ya deux mois et donc du
candidat pour contrer toute cette hype
autour parce que le vainqueur des
candidats jouent le magicien du monde et
ça c'est pas je démontre une coupe du
monde alors ça avec l'appellation est
trompeuse car quand tu gagnes ça en fait
combattu avec moi il faille en fait ce
que justin a tourné en fait sa demande
coupe du monde mme étudiants payent du
champion du monde pour autant ça qui
pourrait changer le nom gérard faire
super coupe intertoto sans vie par
exemple et voilà quoi c'est une coupe
intertoto qui s'appelle ligue des
champions en fait il bon sens et
après le tournoi est assez fort et quand
même dur à gagner etc mais le but ultime
en fait de ce tournoi c'est pas
tellement de le gagner en soit c'est
d'être finaliste comme ça tu es qualifié
pour les candidats qui ne te qualifie
pour la lacc
mais c'est ça le vrai but en fête du
tournant en fait n'importe qui
troquerait son titre de cette coupe du
monde pour dire ah tiens où je
qualifiais ça qui est plus important
satellite soit quelque part ouais je
suis j'ai des chicken on écoute on
regarde vraiment les français apprête à
la chaîne internationale qui montre un
peu tous les joueurs
il montre un peu tout dire on est
surtout là pour suivez les joueurs
français en fait disons que c'est un peu
l'objectif de nos chaînes françaises la
chaîne française essaie de suivre
francophones mais c'est de suivre les
joueurs français et francophone la fin
j'en avais peut-être des belges ou quoi
ma chanson danse et chante à il parle
français mais pas tant que ça en fait
apparemment pas assez pas cet autre nom
mais en fait c'est ça pourrait être
calme et québec canada mais met donc de
base en fait à la chaîne internationale
où il te montre un peu tout quoi
le record pour un français dans cette
compétition c'est quoi je crois que
c'est maxime dominant ouais il l'a fait
plusieurs fois fine 2000
bref il va qui demi aux six autres en
rognant dizy montrent tout sauf baky
battu en fait ils savent qu'on a la
chaîne française pour montrer ben ali
donc du coup ils disent vas aller sur la
chaîne française s'ils voulaient voir
baky enfin en vrai c'est logique je
crois que les français sont en train de
battre l'estonie au basket doit ce
qu'ils disent normal ça m'a l'air fou
vois pas à quel joueur de tennis fr et
toutes époques peut-on comparer pâquis
et max peut pas c'est dur à faire la
file non en fait je pense qu'il est
moins de spectateurs ce qui avait ce
genre de premières pages switch qui
mettait beaucoup de spectateurs en fait
séparément des spectateurs qui son père
parti c'est juste qu'il ya un truc de
premières pages qui s'est barré ne
premières pages sportives way et c'est
ça qui fait qu' il ya beaucoup moins de
spectateurs
j'étais sur ce que j'expliquais twitter
c'est qu'il y avait tant de monde
c'était grâce à ça et du coup voilà bon
on a plus qu'à attendre
avant je remette une chute de trois
minutes femme a passé bien le vermont
ouais
saxon souffre-douleur basket et pas que
ce genre de partie je poussais tellement
chiant à jouer ce genre de position de
proposer l'une autour des vitres de
aurait fui de tournai ne peuvent pas
français tu seras profite de tout
annuler la tête était bien quelques
coins jeux normaux tu fais du chiro de
roide et 3 et wii mais je sais mais bon
tu es d'accord que c'est relou attendez
quoi qu'il en soit 25 on a retourné un
reprenait 1 re 2 ok vous en tirant des
six en d3 ou quoi et là tu nous aimes et
si le veut pas il fait froid et fuite
alors marc tour d un rôle c'est s'il est
un peu obligé rouaix abbas est souvent à
des retours d'évitement hype obligé mais
bon c'est une drôle de brefs lui touche
pas bref 6 voilà un coup comme ça pour
venir tant d un maire me mange mange bon
afin d'être en vain de faire un coup à
la pause et déjà mais bon ce que l'autre
axe est on leur dit avec à redire
croiser étroite et peut-être pas génial
vert td cats iv qui attaque tout ce
qu'on sait à 4 es con ça poussait et là
tu fais nul la seule inconnue pour
trente ans plus tard
hier c'est le genre de parties qui sont
pas ou tu t'amuses pas à quoi tu kiffes
pas quand tu vas tu t'amuses pas
beaucoup on avait nos baskets
bravo bravo les français a baissé pour
wesley sonck une belle équipe va à temps
même si notre équipe ces jeunes sont
moins forts que la france parti de merde
aujourd'hui la purge quoi bon j'espère
que ça va aller vite en fait parce que
si ça dure quatre heures en fait c'est
un peu obligé d'aller vite dans le sens
où tu as que 30000 de rage même moi
j'attends le coût 30 ans fait enfin vous
31 si je vois pas de serrage de mains ou
2,31 non plus ça on est pas on n'a pas
du tout c'était espère à doha quant au
match retour va demain alors on nous
explique objections pour la dixième fois
c'est par contre toi mais c'est la
centième fois qu'on me demande si magnus
ne joue pas pour se qualifier au
candidat au cas où ils perdraient compte
nian le truc c'est qu'en fait le joueur
qui perd le match championnat du monde
et de toutes façons qualifié d'office
comme on disait s'il ya un problème dans
le règlement parce que ma glisserait
même le droit de jouer les candidats en
vrai donc il ya vraiment un souci de
règlement le règlement est très mal fait
et car le sel on profite il a tout à
fait le droit c'est juste ce règlement
qui est mal fait et carl seine qui
ferraille nationale on lui donne le
droit de ce fameux tournoi il envie de
le faire pour ajouter une ligne à son
palmarès sa composition qui l'a jamais
gagnée
et puis toute façon d'ici le championnat
du monde autant qu'ils jouent un peu
pour pratiquer des chèques réel sur un
échiquier et donc bassine envie de le
faire et le fin mai juste oui la règle
devrait bien oui mais non tu peux pas
vous se rend deux fois peut-être qu'ils
fictif importe c'est vraiment un sens ou
dans l'autre mais sans excès avec arsène
pourrait théoriquement jeu les candidats
je le rappelle avec un débat il ya trois
ans parce qu'en fait c'est pas écrit
dans le règlement que le champion du
monde n'a pas le droit d'y participer
en fait il a été obligé de lui envoyer
une invitation willow avril a refusé
mais il aurait très bien pu déjouer donc
en fait c'est juste qu'ils savent pas
écrire un règlement nos échecs on a
quand même l'habitude qu'ils sachent pas
écrire des règlements ça arrive souvent
sur un niveau de compétence générale m
non ça c'est ça en général ça paraît
normal en fait mais l' inverse ce rêve
étrange bavella c'est quand même le truc
le plus évident est vrai mais bon hein
regarde tout le reste est du coup si tu
gagnes les candidats et pas de match 1
je crois qu il aurait pris le 2 rives
c'est peut-être ça sera que la c2 chance
de garder mon titre en fait ça tienne
les candidats soient bon monsieur ya une
poche mais oui bah c'est pas étonnant en
fait quand tu vois tout le reste
honnêtement c'est juste normal qu'il y
ait des tels trous dans les règlements
baïla healy costauds quoi et même le
truc de la coupe du monde c'est quand
même costaud lui ségal bien con c'est
très con mais sa mère - parce qu'en fait
je suis pas con dire en fait les
candidats c'est quand même un truc c'est
le cercueil basse et le nom le candidat
et le nom lui même c'est pour être le
candidat du changement
melrose examen depuis plus de 70 ans fin
et 70 ans on va dire en soixante dix ans
ils n'ont pas pu faire mieux alors que
la coupe du monde c'est vrai qu'ils ont
fait récemment dont tu dis peut-être que
20 ans ouais mais pas pour qualifier
c'était juste un truc de donner un titre
enfin il se passe te coupe du monde un
truc hybride que très bizarre mais cette
qualifie depuis juste dix ans peut-être
pour pour les candidats moi je dis c'est
beau parce qu aux échecs
on va essayer un regret qu'il n'y a pas
de corrélation entre intelligence et
avoir bien joué et chacun stratégie les
paravents de corrélation et que dirige
et rampeau compétents non plus non plus
mais c'est beau moi je trouve que c'est
beau oui c'est vrai que c'est une
question se poserait à des forts de
shaktoi de brumath machin c'est
peut-être pas de l'incompétence à mon
avis c'est pour monter la règle du droit
des candidats si le champion du monde y
participe et c'est pour faire de l'art
hype ah non non mais c'est quoi ton
suffit de passer comme si
n'investissez pas faire de vagues
soissons et delahaye qui aurait du monde
qui regarderait chez moi j'ai du mal à
voir notre sport vous pouvoir un truc si
stupide
ça paraît impossible donc dès que tu es
qualifié pour les candidats ni la rue du
nom tu ne pourras pas y participer aux
quarts à la cohésion d'un verre les
autres joueurs qui sont qualifiés aux
candidats ne joue pas la coupe du monde
donc nepomniachi et rajab or je ne pars
ainsi pas parce qu'en fait ça sert à
rien ils suivent la logique en fait
comment dire il ya la règle comme elle
est écrite il ya l'esprit de la règle
l'esprit de la règle c'est que si tu es
qualifié tu ne joues pas ça c'est
l'esprit de la règle
c'est comme ça que c'est compris c'est
comme les candidats cités déjà champion
du monde tu les joues pas oui mais après
il ya la règle comme elle est écrite où
tu peux en profiter mais comme ça existe
aussi dans notre vie de tous les jours
où tu as des mares loup qui vont
profiter d'une loi qui est mal écrites
pour faire de la merde mais gers est
complètement légal c'est exactement le
même truc tu à l'esprit c'est pas y
participer c'est évident mais tu as le
droit non mais tu as et pour résumer
c'est quand j'ai aussi que lisbonne
n'avait pas écrit que t'avais pas le
droit d'utiliser un truc mais électrique
pas du coup tu pour en mettre un lien
mais c'est pas qu en règle ont fait
valoir ses droits
quelque part c'est ça c'est que tu
interprètes la règle dans contre
l'esprit de la règle de du truc mais tu
les tue le tue l'interprète dans ton
intérêt mais pas tout à fait le droit
attention c'est courant c'est courant
est donc il n'ya pas de ya pas de
problème avec ça c'est assez aux gens de
bien décrire la règle
pas d'histoire de marketing les gars
arrêtez de penser qu'il ya du marketing
à 200 il ya 200 spectateurs sur le truc
de la fidh
il ya personne qui regarde aucun tournoi
n'y a pas de nacre en grand succès il ya
en organique 6000 personnes sur le truc
officiel de chess comme fayat personnes
qui regardent punch m4 va faire 50 fois
plus d'eau n'est en soi pas de marketing
ces grandes alors faut quand même que ça
va attendre fin août
ok les de noël d'autres tournois ou pas
spécialement j'en sais pas plus oui
c'est le contraire c'est comme si
c'était très populaire et que c'était
très regardée comme dit monsieur
monsieur bout mais rossi pourrait pas le
faire ce que la toile grand public
j'aurais tout le monde qui égalerait 9
août
là c'est parce qu'il ya personne qui
regarde ce qu'on peut faire comme ça
n'ont ils pas de sordo chapeau que
chambre 4 on dit en foot le pays de
l'autre qualifié d'office se retrouve
quand même dans une poule de
qualification de faire des maths oui
mais c'est des matches amicaux qui
compte parmi les lignes pas d'autres
équipes
oui ce n'est pas du tout pareil c'est
comme si la magnus ils avaient le droit
de participer mais que les gens qui
jouaient contre lui était pas éliminée
quoi battus fait un championnat et que
le mec s'ils gagnent ce compte pour rien
et que tu prends le deuxième qui est
champion mais en plus c'est magique dans
les qualificatifs à l'euro je me suis
renseigné
en fait ça donne pas pour les matches
comptent pas en fait même adjani de
match donc c'est complètement différent
là c'est panique à lille sort des gens
et en plus comme je disais on joue pas
deux places qualificatives fonds dont
vous-même 4 ici sur les 6 mai puisque on
donne aussi des places pour les grands
prix fille qui redonneront 2
c'est l'inconvénient c'est quand même
énorme ces cieux c'est sûr à 1000% c'est
de l'incompétence en fait et ce sera pas
changée pour la prochaine à banon et ça
va rester comme ça en fait vous revenez
dans deux ans ce sera toujours pareil
nature personnes qui regardera il y aura
toujours les mêmes cinq mois plus 4
on sait que le format est bien enfin
c'est avec knockout c'est ce qu'il ya de
bien mais en fait tu veux quand même
trois semaines et fait le truc qui a pas
deux mais en fait c'est vrai qu'ils
pourraient raccourcir la cadence sert
peut-être deux parties par jour et puis
voilà un jour un match à jouer un match
en dix jours c'est réglé même pas battu
voir et prendre moins de joueurs aussi
en vrai oui ça 128 ça pourrait suffire
ouais c'est un peu ce que georgia
cookies djoko qui va faire les qualifs
du grand chelem quoi elle et qui élit le
200e mondial alors qu'il est déjà
qualifiée d'office pour andré langlois
et mais il a envie quoi donc oui mais en
fait tu peux le faire mais tu peux pas
te inscrire trois principales ça fait si
tu joues les qualifs étaient déjà
qualifiés pas le droit de le faire mais
j'ai eu peur
c'est pour ça que j'ai que là dans cette
logique là pourquoi pas moi je serais
pas content si magnus père avant les
demi finales du coup il perd son titre
de champion du monde sait qu'il a perdu
les qualifications au truc qu'il a et du
coup il perd son titre
et là ce serait logique ça pourrait être
écrit dans le règlement pas le droit de
jouer mais donnez vous êtes passés en
vip mais du coup ça te sens tu mets en
danger ça pourquoi pas à la rigueur
david ça passe l'envi juste rien tu vas
pas d'homme c'est vrai je n'ai pas droit
comme ta loi d'où les cahiers de roland
garros italie mais il y a personne qui
va le faire en fait c'est quoi un bon
coup mais je voulais qu'elle juste est
qualifié mais autant que ce serait
condamner jouer les le truqueur monte
bien chaud tu te bien monsieur la terre
je me suis bien fatigué en jouant ville
dizaines de 7
c'est bien faire des glissades bien phu
vrai que les moyens d'accéder aux
candidats arrivent après la coupe du
monde assez ce qu'ils font en fait
d'arriver jusque là il ya une wild card
pour à dire bof on sait pas vraiment
pourquoi
et il ya déjà les deux joueurs qui
jouent le match donc né paul karle scène
qui sont qu'à fin qui sont un des loges
qualifiables
celui qui perd sera qualifié l'autre
sera champion du monde donc en vrai
c'est le calendrier est complètement bon
bah tu as à tora le tournoi et l'auf
manette aura des grands prix donc 1
c'est que le règlement n'est pas le même
chez les femmes puisque carey chiens et
l'agglo sont déjà qualifiés pour les
candidates eux oui mais ils sont venus
jouer quand même et c'est la même chose
j'espère une des places parce que mais
bon après pour les filles la petite
différence quand même même si je suis
complètement contre ça change rien mais
je comprends plus la démarche l'une
l'agglo d'une gare yatch qui n'a pas ce
qu'ils ont quand même moins de revenus
que les hommes beaucoup moins et pour
elle en fait ya des groupes prix par
rapport à ce qu'elles gagnent sur la
saison donc il ya un peu le côté où
elles sont sans gagner d'argent ce qui
n'est pas le cas pour les hommes qui ont
beaucoup plus de prix dia les grandes
questions les tournois privés et
entraîneur ce que tu as l'argument du
roi et magnus il a besoin de jouer bas
je voulais grande chez sourit la refuser
il a pas il n'a pas hélas pas voulu
participer serait crapuleux truc en
roumanie mais bien sûr donc à ça compte
pas vraiment oui j'en ai beau il fait
les grandes chez sourd il a besoin de
rigueur aussi pour se chauffer mais là
il est plein de personnes
bah oui il fera peut-être un film quoi
j'en sais rien je pense que c'est son
truc de merde mais c'est intéressant qu
elle qui domine pas et chip cox qui
soutiennent qu ils parlent de leur vie
d'avant il a déjà battu une fois ci
comment ça a pu perdre et où il se
présente quand même largement mais je
crois qu'ils la centrale on danse on en
parle qui sera vont airbus il suit pas
une progression de 2,2 d'ovni quoi il
monte en puissance gentiment balle à
roscoff en fait de ouais ouais non ils
vont passer
alors attends on a réussi une petite
blague femme que tu dois pas connaître
d'aller regarder les parties de tabac tu
as et en fait s'il est mieux on doit
dire on n'a pas choisi de mourir le
bagne iranien inquiète on n'a pas pris
le bon je crois pas pris de venir y est
encore bien quoi remède à chaque fois
avancé parti ou un fonds n'a pas dit à
rennes les frérots gars c'est pas de
chance
lévesque vague est vague et vallées ou
candidats comme un bon nom changera pas
il va rien joué en fait il ya peut-être
eu en équipe de france n'a pas pris le
bonne iranien ah bah voilà la petite
pierre boudreau ils font bien le
structurel et bref cette heureuse qu'il
fera bien un peu froide et 3 à 4 km vers
l'est pas qui je viens d'arriver à
l'ordre au pour lvl
et là ça va faire trop pour bâti
normalement nouvel essai signé bas qui
se joue encore ça devrait pas durer très
longtemps si c'est méchant de dire cela
quand même oh c'est une petite blague
pendant ce temps dans la fioriture elle
est bien plus fort que d'appât tabac et
dans tous les cas mais bon c'est marrant
car en fait lui la folie la folie douce
au drapeau français il perd au premier
tour celui jamais arrivé oui même quand
il a joué à 15 ans il étale au troisième
tour contre dubaï où il avait battu
nouveaux faits ils avaient perdu contre
avec super fort après et du coup là il
prend le truc français il se fait
éliminer et à un autre iranien qui
marche super bien enfin c'est drôle on
n'a pas vraiment un jeu fun
ouais juste un mini tour des stades
juste en attendant en bref cet hommage
en attendant la turbo d'euros car la
question un peu gentiment fait c'est sa
griffe choc c'est chaud c'est chaud on
ferait pas clair à doha d'o'reilly était
pas content et très énervé dans tweet de
guy alors dans un autre site internet
c'est pas parce que ils ont dit oui bon
bah je suis à booster of tu as battu
guéri mais tu te fais surprendre au tour
d'après par un joueur beaucoup moins
fort douar béni oui et non détrompe toi
j'ai refusé look lui déjà fin j'ai le
même niveau que lui et je suis calme
champion d'alsace bachand ont fait il
comprend pas pourquoi c'est une surprise
alors il comprend pas par elle mais qu'à
16 ans c'était en mode genre oui tu as
vécu guéri et grosse surprise il
permanence la région pas de doute c'est
une surprise respectez moi mais je suis
une grand maître en fin d'interview les
a défoncé non plus tout comme je suis
gros matches sont programmés invasion
c'est pas une surprise que je rate un
gamin de 16 ans en fait il m'a déjà
battu son plein
très fort pépite fabien les visages ski
fis five years ago
une catharsis rancoeur mais où il était
très énervé il a même requis avait
envoyé un tweet après tout à faire les
autres se sont excusés isis son père
était très mauvaise excuse
les gens qui discutent tu n'as pas tu
n'as pas tout excuser mais il est excusé
mais après un gars qui a répondu
al'excuse bon alors qu'il est normal et
tu t'excuses mrt l'excusé pas de bornes
wi alors oui complètement
parce que tu n'as pas supprimer toutes
les attentions
donc c'est
ces défauts cescut son c'était
exceptionnel le bon sens un petit buzz
et du coup je suis pour lui les grosses
surprises sur est une visite peine
surpris gendarmes adjoints et j'ai fait
était très heureux par soirée tout aimé
les chansons dans leur malchance camani
fin c'est dur c'est certes échantillon
de radjabov mamediarov un monde treize
autres safari mammadov un bon voila tu
vas pas de vie dit fatigué oui enfin
c'est normal est complètement nu le 27
détrompez-vous d'etel teitel comme
visite
mais non mais non ils ont un coup à
jouer en fait loin d'aller prendre la
place aux africains et celui qui en
grosse forme ces faits dassin il ya une
20 points elo enfin que là et je
connaissais pas il fait comme son
tournoi je crois que mathieu a dit qu'il
était très faible
à rl il marche saison tendance après
vous demander pour la chaîne clash entre
la chambre car elle s'offre un beau
champion en fait il est une malle tous
les faillites ou le temps mal en fait on
a déjà une partie de tennis boxe
ouais c'est pas comment ils gagnent 1000
gaye il retourne sur notre plus de quoi
tenir tiendront à une pub pour pas
oublier où on est bien sûr si ça termine
maintenant d'avoir mis à ses pubs
très important d'ailleurs c'est marrant
voyez qu'il ya quand même beaucoup de
cul comme vous parlez du marketing pour
l'événement il ya quand même énormément
de public qui suit la partie de ma nuit
ça m'évoque le marketing de son le même
temps quoi viendront de marketing pour
se rendre à la salle est comble un promu
en liga soit y'a que des trucs proche de
quoi dégoûter un putin torse nu sur le
sur le cheval comme toby jones come back
in anger à face avec ça la position nul
pour pousser son adversaire à l'erreur
chez en match il est vrai je connais pas
grand chose à pousser alors pourquoi pas
pourquoi on se poserait pas la question
inverse pourquoi son adversaire n'en
citerai pas bas qui a le à le laisser
pousser pour que tu vas avoir d'une
imprécision et le battre non mais vous
êtes ça va arriver d'ailleurs face à
nous qui ont enfin du 8 mai ça a besoin
aussi un en fait vu le profil des deux
je pense pas je pense pas que ce soit
des gars qui se passe vraiment plaisir
de jouer ça à 4
la position de ba qui nous fait un peu
peur pas non non mais disons oui en tout
cas puis on n'a aucun problème ferait
bon elles veulent et comment aimer l ça
fait turbo d'euros je rejoins problemi
ce qui ne cherche pas les problèmes
exactement ça je pense et baky qui
propose boss ouais enfin
ça dépend juste comment il la position
est l'autre lune du petit avantage noir
ouais moi je veux bien croire mais à bhl
c'est juste le roi un poil plus actif
autre raison j'aurais sûrement pas avec
les blancs avec les noirs pourraient y
penser mais je le ferai pas parce que ça
me ferait chier non mais bon j'aurais
envie de rentrer à l'hôtel en manger une
petite salle et anne-k aurait le truc
c'est que peut-être pu rodriguez de
l'essayer j'ai noirci jamais par miracle
je gagne ce truc tu veux pas perdre ma
je serais super bien et puis façon que
je veux pas perdre mon sang dans une
heure ou maintenant ils pensent pas à
nous quoi alors une notice d'un tweet de
baky non mais des fois tu as des motifs
et d'autres tweets qui ont ils veillent
à 24 heures c'est pas possible tu
regardes la minute et le contre était
posté ce soir 17 maintenant après ça
peut être matin
jusqu'à demain ça va être chaud un devin
sajoo chauds les marrons il probablement
il y aura des partages
j'espère en fait parce que si on fait
deux nuls au mieux qui les départageront
bon parce que le contrat était garantie
tu as vu qui de l'avis d'autres ce matin
que j'ai sorti avec mathieu bain qui qui
perdent et maquillée cheveux quand même
qui peut le stopper
peut-être la 5g tu vois je vous pose une
question doit cesser et partage contre
nancy avec une photo de manu ce qu'enfin
nature ans aux élections puisque même
magnus peut stopper maquis enfin nature
on ne sait pas
cagnes internet je l'espère la compo de
sortir une belle rhinoise la question se
pose mais quel est l'intérêt de jouer
italienne alors que ont peu de sang sur
tout un tas de choses pour égaliser
aussi les échecs c'est fondamentalement
égal comme jeu donc tu essayes d'avoir
une position moins égale que les autres
le torrent de gagner mon plat
bas-rhinoise normal si souvent annoncé
finale il fallait bien un bouquet de
choc aux candidats ou quoi n'était pas
loin elles appellent tous à gao oui bon
je parte ya aussi bach où ciba qui peut
le battre a battu ses records avec un
tri tron s'agit de la plus grosse
bataille bat qui sait pas qui tu vois
équipe au micro on dit fuck you steve
accès exceptionnel voilà qu'on tourne
des trucs comme ça en fait ouais mais en
fait j'ai trouvé comme ça toujours au
rap avec baky qui avec un trio poséidon
aurais tu vois pas qui en pêcheur dans
la pub un peu une barbe blanche et tout
et il va il prend le bateau avec son
bonnet être réservé quoi
bac il a quand même une certaine
puissance comique bien ce qui correspond
à l absurde il aime l'humour absurde et
j'ai remarqué
et quand tu fais de l'humour absurde il
met toujours un petit temps de pause
quand on live pour être bien sûr en fait
quand et pas en live est normal il
rigole tempo décanter en live en fait
s'il assure le type petit moment
d'hésitation quoi la vraie qui voit se
marrer c'est encore plus drôle que tu
vois le bas qui calcule toutes les
variantes pour voir et à combien de
chances pour que ce soit surtout pas
baba qui calcule jusqu'au bout ok 90%
des cas si je peux y aller je valide
[Musique]
baky money les attrapera tous quoi qui
est légitime sortir de la coupe du monde
il est panne ou steam traque
ouais on interview à la fille docile et
fantastique tu as vu les internautes
bagdad un peu trahi 3 accent français à
fabas et j'adore l'endroit des petites
phrases machin petite blague oiseaux
nicheurs sylt en valais petit punch line
quoi tu vois au passage les pros après
tu te dire des petits bandits spagnolo
mieux quand tu as et c'est bon quoi mais
signe que huawei ayats hommes dessinent
qu tu sens que à tout moment la fille
fait aucun effort pour faire l'axé
anglais passé pour moi y ait un truc
mais de tout temps fait il c'est
extraordinaire
la grande bâtisse historique free c'est
l'accent pakistanais je me remets film
on est de retour femmes
mon purines tu réfléchis on sait pas
trop à quoi j'ai 5 06 il est relou en
fait joué le coup en beauce inc
bastien hugues sa partie bas on va voir
tes sens inverse harper un peu pressés
mais ils n'ont pas changé la caraïbe ils
ont quatre cas mais en plus ils changent
pas les îles et replace pas quoi c'est
pas possible et magnus changer échangé à
faire dhr color bichonne droit
ça va être une instance draw un bon
esprit qu il fait son match mais après
c'est le seul petit défaut qui peut
exister dans ce format moi j'adore donc
c'est pour ce format sont tout le temps
adopté mais c'est vrai que vers la fin
ça sert beaucoup plus la vis aux
rebelles plus personne de perles et un
peu de mes d'ailleurs peut-être le faire
matches aller retour
tu fais que une pertinente ressortent à
l'éventail nord c'est la vie et puis bon
mosti annuler près tu fais un rapide
couleurs inversées un blitz ou l'inversé
et puis un armageddon vas tu veux
vraiment faire un match par jour notre
avance m'aidera beaucoup de surprises
bah tant pis on va t'emmener gendarmes
je me sens le dire mais ou alors tu
vires les longues
oui mais ça va jouer deux rapides encore
mieux mais bon tu vires les longues qui
fait 4 rapide et du coup il ya moins de
chance et plus les meilleurs qui gagnent
ça va plus vite c'est mieux pour le
public c'est mieux pour tout le monde en
fait oui mais d'autres ont pensé pas
départi lentement que non mais tu es
d'accord c'est bien d'ailleurs les jours
où il ya le plus de monde dans le dans
le chat est dans le public c'est les
départager c'est plus intéressant je
sais pas
trop basses 34 mais en fait juste tu
fais un tournant sur 25 jours par la cia
rien dans aucun sport c'est comme ça les
regarde la coupe du monde de foot parce
que tu as plein équipe te faire les
poules les machins il veut fasse
toujours en même temps mais l'en but tu
fais vraiment mon jeu tout le monde dans
le temps ça c'est comme une coupe du
monde où tous les matches avaient lieu
en même temps il ya eu quand même ça
durera un mois
annoncée hier par mois parce que tu fais
un match tu fais une poule une poule un
machin clé publique et le temps d'un peu
tout regarder quoi la queue du rapide ce
serait évidemment le mieux pour
développer le sport si vous voulez
vraiment faire du marketing qui ferait
ça mais c'est pas que du marketing en
vrai parce que les plus forts en rapide
sur les différents longue in fine et du
coup même les jo c'est à dire que ça
dure que deux semaines région et puis tu
as plein de sports différents enfin ses
parts à manger au campus a laissé le 30e
ou la drogue peut tomber à sadr city a
proposé
le dernier coup je regarde ça c'est nul
c'est bon ça y'a pas nul tu as fait tu
te barres ouais t'as bien raison
moi aussi mais là c'est le défaut du
temps dans fait trop longtemps
ouais ouais au bout d'un moment tu en
fait quand on a une journée comme ça tu
as une baisse de régime forcément là les
partis eux s'ils sont vraiment encore la
partie de maxime elle était intéressante
oui oui non monsieur jiva le nouveau
témoin gens se demandent mais on la
montre comme ça tiens regarde ça est-ce
que ça intéresse donc les causes and
demons brute qui va proposer 5 ces logis
maccabi ça peut jouer longtemps ça fera
ou pas ils vont se presser option ils
vont échanger un moment puis et puis
droit et attend encore pour si jamais
c'est drôle ouais ben ayad rossi jouent
un couple ont joué c'est un couple on
joue ce thème à aimer kramnik serait que
faire les départage avant le avant le
match assez extraordinaire ça ça moi je
suis plutôt content c'est comme tu les
tirs aux buts en 20 matches de foot et
séjours et bien sûr ça qu'ils m'ont
parlé de se [ __ ] un chien ça rend fou
et non en fait il a juste des choses
simples à faire faire les échecs en
rapide pour qu'ils aient plus de public
et c'est tout au bout d'un moment c'est
simple tu fais deux circuits en fait
face on est les champions c'est une fois
tous les deux ans tu pourrais faire une
année les rapides à est longue un nom
mais j'ai roulé en mouvement
kraft va prouver s'est qualifié en étant
d'avoir éliminé vrai alors attends un
truc très important tu sais peut-être
pas non ce qu'en fait bac bac qui
tiennent donc pas qui représente le fc
banik oui
donc si il gagne la coupe du monde
samedi qui sera qualifié pour l'un c'est
baky qui voulaient candidat mais c'est
cramique qui jouera le match à bayonne
est important oui mais qui c'est rami
peut pas y voit juste pour la petite la
justice en la petite dax parce que
kramnik en fait ne s'est jamais
qualifiée pour un match du championnat
du monde mais il a été champion du monde
sans jamais changer se qualifier par des
jeux politiques on va dire ça comme ça
ouais c'est vrai ces jeux politiques que
ce soit qu'il en était partie prenante
ou pas ça reste des jeux politiques oui
c'est les échecs le mec ne s'est pas
trop fait le mec à faire vu un match
contre chir of wales et quand même lui
qui a été qualifié petits sets chauffeur
dû perdre ce match
c'est extraordinaire il a perdu la
demi-finale et salah ben ça lui a permis
de se qualifier pour la finale
extraordinaire mais c'est les échecs à
son avant bras ça joue on y met les
longues ça permet de réduire la force
des prépas alors celle inverse scp 2021
ça pour la peine la longue ça augmente
la puissance des prépas bien au
contraire mais ça c'est vrai que c'est
contre logique pour les joueurs amateurs
je peux comprendre que tu penses comme
ça passe quand amateurs tu penses comme
ça j'étais préparé moi je alors que
celle inverse
15 en fait tu as l'impression que ça va
finir vite je connais c'est un cette
sensation en fait tu sais que tu dois
partir mais tu dis bon c'est à dire
encore cinq minutes je reste en fait ça
peut durer une heure et demie way et
pourquoi en perdant et a été qualifiée
ouais c'est une longue histoire mais je
profite du nombre eût préféré jouer
contre cramique donc ils ont dit non
jour est quand même content kramnik en
gros c'est un peu comme si karl scène là
ils disaient pas en fait je veux pas je
compte mener paul richier je joue contre
mvl vous auriez dû vous que le match
c'était comme il est deuxième des
candidats ils jouent contre elles
veulent en gros c'est à peu près ça qui
s'est passé pour résumer simplement
mais vous n'y a pas de raisons sportives
coeur et son sportif donc eu en fait il
était champion du monde sur un vice de
procédure c'est vrai après des trucs
civils abattus kasparov
on va du coup ça vachement le titre de
champion et après en plus tu dois pas
trop qualifiés donc il est très lente à
temps d'attenté ça te faire ça non mais
les échecs
en fait si vous connaissez bien et sur
les échecs c'est vraiment une vaste
blague
ac je le dis souvent mais c'est pas pour
rien que les échecs ont été complètement
des médiatisé et que plus personne ne
regarde en fait c'est à force de
décision débiles les unes après les
autres
en fait il que ça depuis un minima 25
ans presque y est terrible c'est que
même le truc qui a fait live fischer
spassky du goût fish en partie directe
après en fait je n'aime pas le mec à
suivre lorsqu'il donnait le nom et puis
après ils ont eu la grosse hype avec les
échecs rapide
les winograd animaux par et tout ça
ouais et du coup une grosse hype dans
les années 90 avec notamment les
tournois rapide qui était plein et les
salles étaient pleines
il y avait plein de public et 500
personnes à paris une sur des pays
d'issoire cette année payant et il y
avait du monde partout et s'était même
ça même été retransmis à la télé en
angleterre donc c'était vraiment très
populaire ils ont arrêté ça ils ont
arrêté les rapides pour repartir aux
longues pour nous rouler et en plus
c'était le moment il ya beaucoup de
regrets parce qu'il y avait aussi le
match kasparov deep blue mais donc quand
kasparov à jouer contre l'ordinateur
c'est un gros moment de hype ça arrivait
beaucoup sur les échecs on rapide à ce
moment là et ils ont décidé de retourner
vraiment une tradition pour autant au
fond de la cave en fait donc 5 dans les
échecs on a quand même
l'habitude quand tu fais des trucs
populaire des tentes de fer en fait le
train de la vie qui a rejeté puis non
sûrement pas et c'est vrai que c'est
très frustrant c'est ce qu'ils sont en
train de faire encore maintenant fait
une orbite à beaucoup truc avec les
tripes et où ils font tout pour pour
couler les échecs en fait c'est un peu
au bout d'un moment quand tu connais
bien l'histoire des échecs c'est un peu
agaçant quoi dit peut-être que 28
septembre ont découlé quell ça reste
comme ça hier soir hier je suis vraiment
posé la question
soixante d'incompétence soit succès ton
but faut surtout pas qu'on en parle pour
faire d'autres trucs grande quand même
c'est que ça c'est une des théories
enfin j'ai deux théoriciens ils sont
vraiment très incompétents ce qui est
possible soit ils font tout pour une
raison x ou y soient pas populaire
enfin je crois dans la position est
vraiment égal après c'est peut-être un
peu plus tard il est du mauvais côté de
la new wave en fait ce truc c'est que le
renard est un peu plus haut donc un peu
mieux placé un peu plus actif mais en
fait je vois pas trop scénario faisant
fait combien avec les naufragés cinq
lots de crème qui ont passé que les
blancs monts de claquer une pièce dessus
au pire des cas une pièce de plus la
gamme de fer a changé tonnelle dame
rapide puis c'était rigolo shiren
n'attirait pas les sponsors donc en fait
ça veut dire que si tu attires pas les
sponsors tu peux te qualifier pour une
finale de championnat du monde et tu
joueras pas d'accord c'est un peu comme
si la l'euro l'angleterre mais en fait
non l'italie on veut pas légion au final
ils ne doivent pas assez de ramener la
france renaît la france comme ça arbitre
un crunch c'est mieux en fait soit c'est
du sport soit c'est juste un truc il ya
aucun aucun sport et uranus de sa plus
de fric tu joues enfin peut-être bill
gates et des rêves la finale donc dès ce
soir ce sera mieux les meilleurs et
pourquoi j'avais juste de fric onesta
enfin c'est une bible et hausse dans
l'espace le total est l'homme qui est
non je suis quand même un peu plus
ridicule et je veux jouer et latin chiba
cliente à mischa a enrichi magistrats
même très intéressant on donne chevreuil
to the moon
je filme sans rien et puis voilà ça
c'est la vraie finale en fait ce qui se
passe en bas au crime et la boxe c'est
différent
en tout cas on va boxer cette faillite
organisée demi sur un bon organiser
qualif ailleurs c'est pour que les gens
puissent qualifier mais c'est faux fait
de ta toujours des gens dehors le chat
est vraiment beaucoup qui défendent ces
systèmes sont complètement ubuesque
ubuesque ouais on pas dire malhonnête
parce que là pour le truc pour
l'appareil veut dire tu as des chances
équitables tu joues selon les règles tu
gagnes tu te qualifies et tu perds tu
peur c'est la vie il faut se passe a
plus de fric que tu vas jouer en fait
fin mai ou alors tu fais pas de
qualification comme à la boxe et sasuke
aux promoteurs
tu vas aussi c'est possible plus juste
avec ton fric n'y a pas de californie
ouest et le fric béchir a fait un nom ne
voulait pas la jouer non mais c'est à
dire que ton système il feint tu peux
pas tu peux pas en prendre un autre gars
qui a perdu pour le prendre enfin nommé
tatsushi dans le tchat avec moi je
réussis une toiture des gens pour
il a en fait à l'angleterre on les ans
les annonces et vainqueur de l'euro
malgré que ces partis les tirs au but et
à des gains qu'il en est expliqué oui
mais ils ont annoncé normal
trentini qui a retiré le malin a
peut-être réalisé ils ont mis de
l'argent dans leur garde que des dr mais
en fait c'est normal
du coup c'est face à mal enfin nous ont
fait de nous on aime bien le sport avec
fab est ce qu'on aime dans le sport et
on s'énerve c'est le fait que ce soit et
ce chacun est à égalité en fait ça nous
dit qu'une moyenne mais ça qui est faire
moi c'est ce que j'aime dans enfin c'est
une des choses que j'aime dans les
échecs et globalement dans le sport
c'est qu'en fait quand tu pars ya des
règles qui sont donnés et c'est les
mêmes pour les deux ont joué ensemble
voilà et il n'y a pas de lien il n'y a
pas de passe-droit n'y a pas de thune
party pass était plus restreint ten dam
double bass un peu relou ait eu le bac
quand même non geroy volant il revient
encore à tapas et d'action j'ai plus
d'actions total que soit parce que
forcément c'est pas un pay to win voilà
c'est ça et du coup c'est ça qui est
qu'ils font et c'est pour ça que c'est
quand on voit des choses comme ça
forcément tu es pas très content quoi
16h35
ces bonnes notes à qui j'ai fait un
tweet il ya sept arpents ça qu'on a tous
crié bas qui attendent bac et bac é té
si longtemps à sotchi oui on voit
l'énergie très important l'an passé ce
sont les cris baky chez eux quoi j'ai
crié crié baky pour qui a relevé que ces
bokova qui revient au restaurent
ce serait beau quand tu as les joueurs
se retourne à la case quiz
on me dit qu'elle valait redescendu dans
la salle pour crier bacs le 7 contre
sens et 15e d'air j'ai entendu quelqu'un
qui est bas qui dans l'immeuble d'en
face mais c'est sûr j'entends du maïs
est obligé que vous ayez udc en fait il
ya trois ans ont deux trois personnes je
suis sorti à trois personnes qui ont
demandé de faire des sales fit
rencontrer plein de gens issus de la
chaîne du coup très automatiquement même
si vous criez baky et je voulais
vraiment fait c'est sûr qu'il ya des
gens qui vous ont reconnu quoi ça
l'obligé
je suis encore et j'écris baci bon ok ça
tu passes à la main sur un petit fou
étroite a foudroyé de quoi toi tu veux
faire c'est 4 6 2 j'ai bon il va avec
son cheval de cette vraie fausse et un
jour je sais pas berlaimont la police et
les soignants cette année on kibaki sur
nos balcons serait toujours debout
faut-il par l'inventeur que les bugs qui
y
[Musique]
foutraque et ssh c'est pas faux 321
premier réflexe me fait tripper d'un
prises qui a validé cinq cavaliers f4
combien valence à jour et il sait 5
bref 5 et 17 et h3g pas sa part en
foutez de jouer je pense pas qu'il fasse
il en fait un élément très mauvaise
nouvelle
voilà ça va durer 1 aujourd'hui veut
parfaire mon bronzage quoi mais tu
bronze pas normal entre en mai
d'ailleurs une vie tant comme casper
sur mainz a réfléchi silva qui ski fis
pour les sondages me fait tatouer son
portrait script pourquoi les gens qui
est des pâquis 3e 5e caïds et 5 et f4
il vas tu m'en fout en fait je pense
qu'il y en at il envie de faire nul
d'opposer proposer ou n'a jamais osé
dire j'ai tout de suite eu dans son
regard qui vous est là mais je croyais
le roi des cinq par les trois qui est
des cinq non c'est pas con way presse un
peu quand même
il serait un truc et sur ses quatre
marques et gsea passé comme ça
lord il est pas content j'ai trois étés
h5 donc peut-être c4
ces cartes c'est logique après la
paroisse des katja foot rôle important
quand même
wayne on sait qu assez logique en fait
si tu vois kg trois cavaliers h cinq
mois sur l'autre et ses 6 3 et 3 c'est
pas des belles parties aujourd'hui se
battront venir sa bague ses longs en
fait et en plus on n'a pas la cam 1 7
fois et on aurait pu juste regarder baky
quoi ça suffit à soi-même en fait 45 mn
est-ce que c'est tuant baudron lensois
là ils en sont à tomber 5 pouces et 6
tomber tours c'est ça va se retrouver ça
si je peux pas faire ça à cause de ça je
pense sa voiture vos droits chaque jour
fritz troc est ce qu'il avait dit dans
une interview et visites on peut
champion des ardennes jean emile albeau
je dois revenir on voit et c'est bien
c'était chaud le match
contre abdou non mais dites contre
contre contre hannibal beast ouais là ça
va faire nul ouais beaucoup nul
aujourd'hui le beau ni rien entendu
encore mais en fait un petit tour ces
trois dames un ancien dans votre hall va
faire droit aussi à la tête à la foudre
aujourd'hui peut-être que le droit au
bail
mais il ya moins de parties
intéressantes que les autres jours
honnêtement ça plus serré la vis après
joueurs sont fatigués ton moins elles
ont aussi un prendre de risque mais on
peut un jour de repos loi n'y a pas
longtemps
mercredi mais bon ce sont ils bien
reposé du radium
dans un jeu les écarts sont moins
importants entre les joueurs ouais mais
c'était plus ouais c'était plus ouvert
les autres que tu avais quelqu'un qui a
vraiment envie d'essayer de gagner des
autres qui fermait il a fait kg 3 il
veut h4 et le h5
du coup tu revenir l'autre en bien comme
il faut
ça me ferait peur avec les blancs mais
bon avec baky s'agit pas du tout peur
c'est dur d'aller taper h3 ait souffert
du kg 3 5g cats et d'envoyer le pion
après je pense qu'il faut une turbo
drogba qui voit là un hasard il joue
vite quoi
chaque émanant grand prix fidh rapporte
le double du vainqueur que le prix aux
vainqueurs de la coupe du monde
oula ça je pense pas c'est l'événement
en entier mais c'est le prix pour tous
les joueurs je pense pas qu'ils gagnent
plus d'argent au grand prix fica la
coupe du monde je pense pas que baky mvl
fasse exprès de palau candidats pour
aller jouer les grands prix feed c'est
mieux d'aller joint grande chaise tour
entre cartels beaucoup plus d'argent à
prendre beaucoup plus intéressant
alba qui est belle c'est possible oui le
tableau était bâtie pour abbaoui chaque
côté partir de tableaux partie basse du
tableau et sa trace sa route
bon qu'est ce qu'on va faire casse
r le petit fantôme
[Musique]
bon ce que ça va jouer côté casper cgeci
sauce que ça h 4 min du côté du
président pour être sûr qu'elles veulent
arrive en finale et jouer contre baky
ouais c'est ça en fait sombre des
séquelles peuvent être bâties côté
magnus pour bien assurer le coup c'est
platini qui a fait le tirage ce que
celle là encore une chance de participer
aux candidats bah oui il y aura d autres
trucs là les autres tournois way tournoi
de loqman par exemple il sait quoi les
autres places pour les co pour les
grands prix les quatre finalistes et
puis tu as d'autres mairies kg par an
selon le détail mais tu auras d'autres
places acquis mais avec de l'argent
peut-être mais faisait nombre peut-être
mais s'ils viennent qu'on regarde foyer
fixe magnifique si je pense à dos dans
le fond mais un solide comme un g6 les
rois des trois-quarts aile yoder web
ouais complexe
complexe fait quoi traître ok c'est une
autre option pour chasser sans plus sage
et 5 c'est dur à faire si l'on croit
change un pion 28 ans plus tard et tu
vas vraiment pas y arriver
ouais mais c'est sûr que la maison la
maison bacrot c'est une maison sérieuse
assez solides pour ça qu'on s'inquiète
pas du tout tu peux pas des croulants
soufflant de sucre solide devrait
d'ailleurs bastiais ne faut pas trop
essayer de le battre dans ses positions
peut être dangereux quoi l'embuscade
quoi prend pas le relais il est là où as
tu as vu cette course djo s était pas
mal carapace qu'elle marlou des andes
une nouvelle fois quoi marleau trier
juste quand il a roulé avec l'autre à 2
nos remarques à un moment donné ils sont
passés de plus 45 secondes à plus 15
puis sûr que c'est carapace qui
prenaient moins les relais c'est
tellement marlou n'interdit pas ça oui
c'est toujours lui qui faisait signe du
soutien il passe je suis fatigué chats
blogs et pages regarde je suis très
fatigué au visage
j'ai choisi ces deux gars là une petite
montée je vais attaquer comme celle
entre carey donc 1
c'est tellement marlou de monde le vélo
c'est bon parce qu'on très trop fort ou
quoi l'algérie c'était un peu le défaut
de grand art
après laver la pancarte mais peut-être
un monde il en a un peu trop fait il
fallait qu'ils essayent de partir dans
un groupe à 3,4 et après du coup il
aurait roulé pour avoir des médailles
mais c'est bizarre venu au mans il n'est
pas pris le relais pour lui non mais
j'aspire tutorat le bon ok tu sais bien
tchapalo mais c'est beaucoup beaucoup
mieux qu'hier septième sens de prendre
le relais qu il vaut mieux ne prendre
qu'un relais ne jamais attaquer pour
être bien sûr si j'avais abandonné il ya
une chance à 400 mètres de l'arrivée de
m l'attak
c'est bizarre tant mieux après son
interview la fin du monde aucun regret
j'ai de supers sensations mais mon idée
c'est tout le sprint avec thomas b enfin
doute fait des sprints que le gros du
coup le sprint à gaza du coup les filles
ce diamant fin mais c'est complètement
stupide stratégie stratégie dauphin est
d'accord qu'il avait aucune chance à bas
l a pas eu dans ce qu'on a vu ce qui
avait l'air bien qu il était là mais
surtout en art il est hyper formé au
catcheur aussi les bons sprints une
temps monter les deux n'a aucune chance
chartrand se porte pas bien vieux
remparts ou en sprint mais il a été
enfermé à la fin
normand puisses tu prends le relais
avant art tu peux tu peux revenir sur le
groupe et est admiré de médaille je veux
dire à dieu tu parles du grand art
et puis au figaro qu'il te défonce à le
bronze quoi peut-être que revient
patients carapace mais ça sent la torah
leurs deux noms puis survenait sur
carapace qui avec un si long des bandes
art il était tellement chaud il revenait
après tu mettais dans la roue de
carapace su récupérer l'eau tu étais
c'était chaud et au pire tu une médaille
ça se passe mal bref d'être qu'il est à
bloc à ce moment là en sprint il a fini
7e abc sûr mais c'est souvent le
problème avec mon vélo c'est quand un
gars trop fort en fête a failli s'en
fout du coup ils valent jamais roule
avec tellement stupide points faibles
trop fort mais la raison et que c'est
que d'habitude au vélo c'est un peu un
winner takes it all mais là pour le coup
pas du tout le troisième lui prend sa
médaille ça mais quand bien même tu te
retrouves dans le groupe à 8 avec
bernard basset mieux dedans déroulera en
fait tu auras je t'en ailles drap alors
et puis tu auras pas l'argent pour le
voit bien que l'autre il en est une qui
bien que vous regarde s'ils envoient des
gros relais voiture envoyée au moins des
relais de la vitesse des autres devant
et au moins tu joues encore quelque
chose facile on fait toujours rien
on voit sa majorité je pense que les
deux ont décidé de faire nul en fait
mais j'avais fait nul suffisait à se
décider quoi fait vraiment que moi je
pense surtout que goyi préféré voir
carapace gagner plutôt que van marcke
les coureurs doivent sentir qu'il est
chargé qui l'est moins
enfin bon carapace et cabinet hausse
comme un engouement différence soit
propre
moi je pense surtout qu'il court très
mal c'est tout c'est la bonne came n'ya
pas les câbles en fait être très
concentré changement ne bouge pas je
pleurais
dans ces endroits exacts
nankin
bref on embraye a pas grand chose à dire
il peut faire b5 si tu as fait ça
échange suyapa nous y a rien en fait
car moi aussi je pense qu'il est au
rupteur goody au moment où ils passent
pas le relève en arts je pense qu'il
pouvait pas en vrai ainsi le bail peut
pas et même sûrement vrai juste ce que
j'ai pu c'était déjà bien beau jeu
suivent le groupe
non clairement clairement je pense qu'il
n'avait juste pas les jambes a souvent à
ce moment là de la course je pense
qu'ils les avaient pas après jalabert
était très énervé titre soit tu
regardais avec les commentaires non non
en fait il voyait que goût du lot de
commentaires oui très bien joué de
goodwill seulement dernière place ne
prend qu'un relais et il récupère et en
fait j'avais à dire oui enfin un moment
déçu prend 0 reliques mais zéro attaque
tu vas jamais gagné non plus à la mer
noire mauvais tu toi là tu dois cacher
des choses et quand je prépare les rôles
et l'autre au jihad et oui il ne faut
pas leur est de vous en art qui me
laissait faire le boulot à bonnart
pourrait finir je prend pas le relais il
va jamais revenir et finira jamais
troisième fin d'ailleurs même c'est ce
qui s'est passé mais bon il ya un
gouvernement si tu prends pas drôle et
que tu attaques pas d'énergie
mais oui il était pas bien sûr les
accélérations société juste pas bien il
ya bien longtemps maintenant
à wissant la nuit de mardi à mercredi
dumoulin qui peut pas alors c'est
bernard tient évidemment mais moi je
suis pour le [ __ ] anormal de quel canal
et c'est un génie mais je pense que
c'est pas trop son profil parce qu'il ya
c'est un peu vallonné ne provient de
chars il peut faire aussi non non paugam
charmant pas si fort en fait en contre
la montre
c'est soit von arx soit pas trois
favoris je pense vont en art
nana parlons et rohan dennis très fort
sur ron dennis ne fait plus le giraumon
est très très fort une guenon cavagna
non plus à rapallo vous
even poule aussi peu roglit web n'est
pas mal non
ouais mais là il n'était pas en forme
mais oui il est pas mal
à serena qui abrite est un nazi je me
rends mouche rhénan küng à küng non non
il ya trop c'est trop vallonné pour king
tu n'y fera rien puis fram en attend une
petite seconde femme
on est reparti j'imagine que oui
après c'est moi qui ai demandé à la
fille pour 20 kg et demandé à thiès
comme qui demande à la fis pourrait
mutuel parce que sinon on aurait pu ne
pas voir une nouvelle fois
compréhensible en fait parce que c'est
pas comme je dis c'est pas des carmes
filmer les déplace pas fou j'ai un bref
repartir à cette fin il va pas faire à
cause de fouilles trois mois multi dix
fois je dois le roi g2
être en vue chacun ouais dans chaque
coin
le budget était claquée sur les niches
fiscales fight lights et ça on valide et
je pense c'est vraiment de faire un clin
d'oeil et roy f1 mais enfin tellement
absurde
se passe pas grand chose mais le truc
c'est que ça donne l'impression que ça
va finir d'une minute à l'autre et ça
fait déjà beaucoup nous a fait déjà
presque une heure il manque une petite
pub la kippa mais oui ça devrait finir
d'une italo toile et c'est dur c'est par
là là on n'a pas de bol aujourd'hui
franchement les tous les autres jours
c'était bien on a assez le premier jour
où vraiment ses katas 0 spectacle mais
bon comme viser un plus la compétition
avance plus le pas sur le jeu
ouais
donc regarder je suis que ça a l'air pas
mal on va voir sa taille complexes et
leur guise
il est très très bien la notion de moins
ouais et du var marine ans tu prononces
dur à avaler mais je sais pas enfin
l'arrachent
c'est pas un touriste et un nom un azéri
donc rien à voir aussi le vent est
d'ailleurs bien énorme et c'est chaud
wahiba qui il va t'il terre oui c'est
possible
il a rien avancé du tout exception voilà
foutu il a voulu faire bien marrer ça il
peut faire des matches j'aurais pu faire
nul instant t il a commencé à jouer le
gain et on sait pas trop pourquoi
la rente les enquêtes et puis on la voit
de base en fait tu partes avec tellement
de retard et clément et n'aurait pas pu
faire des dessins et qu'il aura bien
placé au centre tous a dit oui bon je
touche à rien là tout d'un coup dix ans
comme partie vraiment bizarre
et qui le presse qui va se présenter de
façon majuscule mais c'est qu'il peut la
gagner
balade j'y crois de plus en plus en fait
va j'y crois pas une seule seconde
pendant l'été si la puce adversaire
simon pegg
après c'est pas pour rien qu'il est 2006
suit we know me suis envolé ces nuls non
mais oui quelque part en vie quelque
part 8 par rapport à baky mais si maxime
pense que le président va gagner ce que
tu as qui est bas qui à 16h35 et maxime
illustrer sa mort
et oui mais c'est à nous on n'a pas la
cam mais face à brême ne pas avoir la
cale mais bon malheureusement max il n'y
a que quatre cadres et déplacé la cam
qui était sur toi et tout en l'air
stressé 2.2 nautique bioware maturité il
ay ay ay clean 2 août en tout temps
prenez sympa enfin il est sympa il sera
surtout sympa quand il rentrera chez
magne c'est beau comme pays la pologne
très beau pays j'aime beaucoup ça
patrick pour lui souhaitant on vous
souhaite de pouvoir rentrer chez lui dès
demain demain soir avant le retour pour
crash au combien on checke ci a pas un
voile à sotchi cracco akouè owo il y en
a 1 demain à fort à perdre 8 sur les
coups de 17 heures 30 il a dit tu viens
tu perds tu prends ton taxi il a juste
le temps de perdre en une demi heure sur
une prépa bas qui est ce qu est et
partir direct à l'aéroport
ça vaut quoi depuis 135 euros datait des
jeux correctement quoi et la rue du bac
maxime tue pas les bouger les choses
pour un championnat qui bouge pas
l'objet tu veux prendre les calmes qui
n'est chez kevin que 6 ne peuvent pas
bouger 1 fr parce qu'à faire avec ses 4
du quattro en avant mais ce rêve au kit
choc complètement mais là c'est déjà pas
si facile trois coups écoute tu as plein
de coups jeudi remet ça mais c'est quand
même extraordinaire que les pions avance
et ça c'est vraiment lui qui a cherché à
batna qui fabrique qui suivront bonne
nuit là il fait un stand mais bon qui a
eu ses trois simples j'ai ici c'était
tout bizarre en fait en fait t'as pouget
en fait tu viens de jeudi coup pour un
jouet est peut-être à remplir et alors
il faut en fait fougères c'est le
terrain pour faire baisser mais servant
un coup de plomb mais pour ça qu'il a
plus de temps à bord du lit saignant qu
elle s ils trouvaient pas et oui c'est
un problème beaucoup trop compliqué pour
moi et les polémistes et champion du
monde de problème c'est qu'elle coule
sur la chaîne m6 ont peut-être plus de
camions a que huit noms accolés calme
fixe en fait comme plots
on n'a que les calmes fixe champions
cherchez problème il va en trouver ah
bah oui là on réserve est oui amel el à
3 kw à jouer en 10 secondes diva je me
sens que vous allez un petit moment
difficile des trois coups c'est beaucoup
20 il va pas tomber mais tu faire trois
coups de merde et on pourrait encore
plus tôt position quoi chose à faire p5
là-bas qui bat sa logique tu peux te
faire plus tard aussi c'est un blender
qui a eu cette non je pense pas que ça
blender mais tu sens que c'est dur mais
il sait pas trop s'il doit faire il a
complètement disparu depuis cinq ou déjà
qu'on doit les pas trop casper magasin
bon bah allez à montfavet le président
abbas et le présent ce serait beau quand
même le quart de finale bat qui est si
plein coït imagine la vie à deux jeunes
qui vient de battre le champion du monde
face au président on s'impose un bail
t'imagines fin août une envie de
demander si bienne qu est ce que la
marche n'est pas trop tôt pour toi enfin
et là oui et si quelques du congo en
face à l'everest baki je m'incline
pourquoi passer cinq mois tu donne accès
à la casse des cinq ans fait alors que b
5 qui fixe un pion sur noye d'être
prendre deraedt garder les accès aux
cases et peut-être faire flouer 3
rentrer en d4 et jouer le mais ça doit
être nul quand même ce truc mais bon tu
leur souffle après tu peux aussi avoir
envie de faire mais ce que j'allais dire
de rien faire pour le moment tant que le
jackpot est en cours s'il fait j'ai cinq
ans fait f100 et toutes les finales
c'est parce que dès qu'il fera fou bd 4
s'échangera l'écart et tu feras hk tu
fixera bref 5 fait plutôt mieux veut
sûrement et kg 3 c'est quoi un prêtre 4
qui avaient lieu deux ans mais qu'est ce
qu'on te rentre chez toi et tu retournes
rien sur tout
as plutôt bien vrai ça en fait tu as
fait un bon coup ouais il a trouvé un
truc de problèmes qu'il soit 3,5
les structures lui va trouver ça trop et
39e court instant sur lequel j'ai trois
tu prends accroît aussi sa grande
demande à trouver un coup une décision
je suis apte à prendre mais je vois pas
en panne à 6-6 jim agit vraiment ça va
pas ça c'est pas assez
tu foutais de retour c'est vraiment
concret mais tu peux faire rosto c'est
mauvais du coup on t'aime plus il a raté
11 5 en fait ouais il a dû rater rey et
du coup il ya un grave si fou des deux
têtes rumeur que six ans après je sais
pas si vous faire aussi survenir si un
seul problème c'est le foot qui est de
la mauvaise couleur par rapport aux
points à 4 et c'est vrai aussi
mais bon peut-être revenir et affectifs
étroits système pourrait du coup il a
joué la fin c'est extra temps ouais mais
bon oui non c'est pas mais au moins il
survécut à ça ils peuvent charente et
l'accueil de venir oui mais je veux dire
on va pouvoir la fin de la partie dans
cinq minutes
aaaaah ouais ça va durer des plombes
encore
ils peuvent faire genre cavaliers deux
fois veuve de foot et 4 ça va être fait
dès 4 ans ça donne cet ostendais je veux
dire en garde le futur de calais dans ce
genre de truc ne prêche pas ici ce que
ça donne des forteresses non quand même
baky qui envoie du rêve oui peut-être
fait un bep 5a bcv à monter dans le
train fou pro b 6 avant de réfléchir à
ça et puis ça marche pas de faire nul
voisine me fait une petite pause donc on
peut dire un fabien quand on pense quand
on se désirent et vous tu veux revenir
reviens moi je reste là je mets des pubs
de toute façon et j'attends la fin
tranquillement merci fabas tout les amis
on perd fab fable qui arrache quitte
après le 40e
j'ai changé de câm pha petit part
terrible et oui casper en difficulté
j'essaie de me re mouchet
ça c'est fait
on va
là de toute façon bas qui est vrai que
ça récupère du temps de partout
/ ava tchétchène ouais mais il fallait
non normalement fait tu dois avoir un
hosting sur la chaîne c'est bizarre je
dois avoir un hosting ans près tu aurais
pu aller dans catégorie chase 1 ça
fonctionne aussi
non je sais pas pourquoi
ce que j'ai une autre cas m'attendait en
train checker cij éventuellement une
autre gamme
il ya une cam mix en fait je peux
essayer de mettre ça là et on verra
peut-être en bas qui ambulants
apparaître et c'était ça la cam qui
z'ont qu'à mix en fait t'as des cales
différentes qui apparaissent
ça peut être un plan
un plan va voir il faut bien que je
regarde l'échiquier attendez j'ai trouvé
ce truc là qui était un peu caché on va
essayer de va essayer d'utiliser l'ipad
gris tchouk well as cannes rondo mais
elle peut mettre peut mettre bas qui de
temps en temps mais on va la tenter
là c'est gris chabat qui fait re 4
grischa ça fait quoi du coup ils ont
terminé la game ça fait drôle et peut
avoir une journée foudre au 1 c'est
possible peut-être que dehors ben ali
qui va qui va s'imposer à feydeau ce qui
peut avoir une chance aussi fait d'os
peut avoir une chance aussi
ça va taper pas le bon iranien contre
martirossian c'est chaud et je chante
longue il est en train de se stabiliser
ok on va on va avoir plus de baky là
c'est sûr
sûr c'est évident que ça peut ça peut
encore le faire on te voit plus vrai
j'ai pas j'ai pas mis la camisa attendez
je vais la mettre en train de rechercher
deux trois trucs que je joue à checker
c'est vrai en fait que le que les gens
qui tombent lost il n'y a pas marché en
fait l'hébergement a pas marché
un gain
en fait
ce niveau là qu'un joueur perde autant
assez rare mais un joueur peut se
retrouver en difficulté au temps et du
coup faire une erreur ça ça peut arriver
perdre autant non mais enfin non ça peut
théoriquement arriver mais c'est surtout
ce fait faire faire une faute parce que
parce que joueur en manque de temps en
fait
des usa peut-être pas fonctionné après
je sais pas vrai
donc le re4 été jouée avec casper qui
doit subir en fait le truc qui se passe
c'est que les blancs une auront du mal à
pousser leur majorité et les blancs
peuvent peut-être poussé la leur dans
une relation peut échanger contre le fou
ça vaut le coup à sa dépense et que du
calcul 1 et montre il montre la partie
de fait d'os
je crois qu'il peut gagner
éventuellement c'est une grosse erreur
de yves itx on va voir
c'est par mon résultat lvl nul avec les
blancs aubin c'est le résultat le plus
logique 1 gagne avec les blancs c'est
dur aux échecs g2 surtout prochain qui
veut quoi il veut cette eia plutôt aux
5,3 g d avoir tout re ont probablement
ils enlèvent sept rois g7 et le truc
c'est que ça ça doit être nul ça fait
longtemps qu'ils puissent nahla elle
doit être nul mais je suis pas sûr en
fait de comment on fait parce que rappaz
les échec par derrière
c'est fou je me rappelle plus de cette
finale ça se fait tellement longtemps
que je n'ai pas vu avec les pions gc nul
avec les pions f je ne sais pas
qui est sa douche je pense que c'est une
île de mémoire mais je n'arrive pas à
voir le plan 2 nuls de tête
sensationnel séguin blanc très possible
en réfléchissant dans la tête je vois
pas comment faire un nul en fait est une
cellule facile max émissaire facile je
vois pas le plan nul
c'est tellement longtemps que j'ai pas
vu ça là on va faire confiance à maxime
faudra regarder un autre jour mais donc
du coup
breux un pion prends ça il ya aussi un
fils échec qui est jouable roi et fuite
forcée
cet ours et 8,3 f7 tourache 8 pour
choper le curage ça ne s'est pas sur un
sais pas qui ça joue à l'arrière foyer
fouet f2 cavalier e 2 donc les ben barka
relief 5 et bas qui va vouloir quoi il
va vouloir wife trois essais d'enfermer
le fou peut-être la gagne et baky
matin la position pour baky petit
avantage petit avantage pour baky
on va voir on va voir peut-être il peut
faire quelque chose
plus pur ou une qui peut se tromper mais
bon il n'a pas été il n'a pas été exempt
de tout reproche
donc ça peut peut-être gagner à voir
vale f5 way peut-être silverware f300
commencé à s'en prendre aux fous si par
vers h4 il pourra peut-être faire qui
est des quatre prises prise et le fou se
retrouve hors jeu du coup faudrait venir
entre 3 faut voir si on peut progresser
faire des exemples quelque chose comme
ça ce que les noirs ont pas des milliers
de courageux fois plus de cases de
cavalier peut plus bouger
il ya plus que roy fc3a roi aussi s'en
fait
sur carré des f-5 qui est des quatre
direct ouais mais ça ça doit pas être
gagnant comme final ils ont créé noir
n'y a pas de raison qu'ils soient moins
bien là c'est peut-être même eux qui
sont mieux je pense que c'est nul mais
de faire pareil tu vas pas rentrer là
dedans avec les blancs il a fait
cavalier 5
on va voir ce qu'ils jouent j'ai dit ah
alain sur dernier a prises prisé fou des
cinq épreuves cinq jours à g4 ça doit
être ça ça marc loubry airwave 7 du coup
ouais non bref cette iapp à 2 tours 4
ok ça peut gagner ça pour voir ben ali
attention parce que pour le moment il ya
deux pions de plus pour martirossian ça
pourrait passer
alors on retourne sur baky on voit pas
trop à la cam
d'ailleurs ça a l'air nul kambakhsh i
way terrible
ouais
qui entraîne bas qui bat qui s'entraîne
tout seul dans la montagne et fraîche il
a joué ici et ben ouais nan c'est obligé
avec fiat comme un ces six minutes de
pub toutes les heures il a joué 3 e 4
est donc du cours f3 fou trois rois 4
parce que l'autre va retourner à gif du
fou rire moi du coup f2 pardon il est un
rêve de ça va peut-être faire nul
avant il s'empare tout seul dans le
maquis en bas qui pour se préparer il
affûte ses ouvertures
qui a trop tube suis d'accord avec vous
mais moi je obligé d'en mettre six
minutes par heure donc j'ai pas trop le
choix après comme je vous ai dit on
pourra faire en france on fera un débat
la suite est-ce que c'est mieux
finalement de faire sans calmes mais ne
pas voir les pubs et d'être tranquille
ou est ce qu'est ce qui vaut mieux avoir
les pubs et avoir les calmes on en
discutera et on verra ce que ce que vous
en pensez 1
on peut faire un petit sondage
maintenant j'ai envie de dire faire un
petit somme si un petit sondage on
mettra tout le monde d'accord on va
faire parler la démocratie allez au sens
large qui va parler
on va voir on va voir ce que vous
préférez on va faire le sondage - c'est
parfait là je pense que baky ça va faire
nul nul qu'on attendait depuis longtemps
le vaudois tête un but à vous pouvez ne
pas voter
voilà gens préfèrent quand même à voir
la pub elecam ça se vérifie
je suis à la gamme qu'on a
malheureusement non enfin si mais en
fait la queue quatre can fixe et y en a
pas sur baky donc âge mais cette gamme
en espérant avoir bas qui en fait
bon ça devrait jouer rapidement
maintenant je pense qu'il va refaire
fouet f2 ce serait bizarre de ne pas
faire peut-être qu'il sent que baky veut
pas faire nul 1
oui pour moi c'est mieux streamés sur ma
chaîne rai après là c'est pour avoir les
calmes à la fin façon c c'était quand
même coup la partie de maxime
donc on va voir si ff de ces pour
répéter après est ce qu'il se dit qu'il
a un g5 qui est plus fort peut-être
qu'il va en profitèrent pour envoyer son
contre eux ça doit être plus fort que
foued de fondamentalement
c'est mieux mais après faut qu on espère
qu'on les ait et surtout sa sont si bas
qui se qualifie contre contre issy
piankov normalement il y aura la cam
a été le plus représentent actuellement
je crois que c'est la russie 1
ils ont gris juke égyptienne coquard
yakine ziegler et feydeau seuil hafiz
encore cinq joueurs il a fait fouet
faisons là on va voir si baky fairway f3
c'est nul je pense pas qu'ils le fassent
pense qu'il va essayer de gagner
non je me suis trompé j'ai pensé qu'il
essaie encore un petit peu mais non il
va répéter les coups donc ça vadrot les
amis ben écoute et petite journée
finalement pas des parties très
excitante côté français on avait les
blancs les prépas sont pas passés les
adversaires ont bien joué après c'est
pas le seul en magnus a fait nul etienne
a fait nul grisha fait nul il reste quoi
vit dietsch fedoseyev fellows qui peut
peut-être la gagne et ce à la 3g 3 il va
prendre h7
ça peut gagner à
tabataba et qui est donc dur maintenant
contre martirossian il ya peut-être y
avoir des résultats mais pas dans les
matches voyez c'est dès 2006 à ces 2006
weis 2006 là on est sûr sur 2006 vs 2005
et shankland vide l'air c'est solide on
va dire que c'est sur les matches qui
restent encore des joueurs un peu moins
bien classés alors après vous dirai pas
qui pue ruine aussi mais c'est déjà
quand même plus solide on a les bacs
je vais rater ça va pas durer durer très
longtemps hélas ces visites qui va
essayer de gratter les pions ça devrait
faire annuler aussi ça devrait faire
grimper de cf allez je me mouche
d'higuain martirossian et deux nuls
intéressants à feydeau cf qui va se
présenter quand même hein une fois
qu'ils en quarts après surtout je crois
qu'il joue le vainqueur de feydeau s'ils
jouent le vainqueur de tabata
martirossian donc tu peux avoir un
feydeau cf en demi finale ce qui serait
une énorme surprise mais ma foi ça
pourrait ça pourrait aller loin
donc attention à lui il est chaud depuis
le début de la compet ouais il est chaud
depuis le début là qu'on peut être
écouté les amis moi je vous remercie
d'avoir suivi ce stream jusqu'ici on va
envoyer un red hat chasse comme et on va
se dire à demain merci à tous ciao ciao
ou là j'oublie d'envoyer une dernière
pub
histoire d'être bien sûr au moins ça là
elle vous embêtera pas merci à tous ciao